Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Britt Law und nach einer längeren Pause begrüße ich alle wieder hier bei CRE und,
wie ich gerade selber festgestellt habe, begleite ich heute ein Thema, was ähm tatsächlich bei all diesen ganzen Folgen bisher,
etwas unterrepräsentiert war, wir reden nämlich über die Natur. Aber wir reden nicht nur über die Natur, als solche, sondern ganz konkret geht es um,
Fledermäuse.
Und um darüber alles zu erfahren, was wir schon immer wissen wollten, äh, dazu begrüße ich erstmal mein Gesprächspartner, nämlich den Florian. Florian, hallo.
Ja, hallo Tim, ich freue mich, dass du heute hier bist.
Ja, herzlich willkommen. Ich bin äh zu Gast, muss ich sagen, ich bin äh jetzt hier bei euch im Fliedermauszentrum in Bad Segeberg, aber vielleicht bevor wir darauf äh mal eingehen.
Kannst vielleicht erstmal erzählen, was äh du eigentlich so machst.
Ja, ich bin,
Biologe und habe mich äh ja im Laufe meiner Ausbildung irgendwie immer mehr auf Fledermäuse spezialisiert. Eigentlich war das gar nicht von Anfang an der Plan. Ich wollte eigentlich mal,
über die Meereskunde zur Polarforschung kommen, hatte aber schon als äh,
ja, Schüler, eine Facharbeit geschrieben über Fledermäuse und fand das Thema.
Da schon interessant, hat aber dann auch gedacht, naja, hast du schon zum Abitur was gemacht über die Tiere? Dann kannst du im Studium auf jeden Fall was anderes machen, aber wie das Leben manchmal so spielt, da gab es sich dann das mal in meiner Heimatstadt in Neumünster,
in Schleswig-Holstein äh plötzlich der Bedarf da war, mal eine Fledermausuntersuchung zu machen.
In den ähm neunziger Jahren. Und äh über den Naturschutzbund, äh beziehungsweise BUND seinerzeit.
Äh gab's da Untersuchungen und da hatte man mich gefragt, weil man sich erinnerte, Mensch, da war doch mal so ein Schüler, der hat auch mal was ge.
So, dann bin ich da wieder äh mit eingestiegen und äh als Studenten brauchte man ja auch ein bisschen Geld und so, das wird auch ein bisschen bezahlt, wenn wir da richtig Datenquartierungsdaten geliefert haben und so. Und so war das dann plötzlich so eine Art Nebenjob neben dem Studium und die Fledermäuse waren immer,
immer da.
Was war das für eine Untersuchung.
Ja, da ging's eigentlich letztendlich darum ähm,
in der, in der Stadt, Neumünster, einzelne Bereiche mal auf äh die Lebensräume der Fledermäuse zu untersuchen, einfach mal festzustellen, was kommt da eigentlich so vor? Das ist interessant gewesen, da ist ein See, der Einfall der See in der Nähe,
und Moorgebiet und ein Stadtwald und so weiter. Und das haben wir dann alles äh über fünf Jahre immer mit Berichterstellung und so weiter zu drit,
ausgearbeitet und das war ein sehr schöne, schöne Nebenjob, als,
als Biologe sogar, man hat ja sonst alle möglichen Jobs im Studium so gemacht, dann äh wenn man da mal das Gefühl hatte, man konnte mit der Profession, die man eigentlich lernt, vor einem Jahr im Studio, immer so ein bisschen anders suggeriert wurde, ne, fingen dann an im ersten Semester, man würde,
am Ende nur noch bei Doktor Oetker Backpulver abwiegen oder solche Sprüche hörte man dann da auch mal. Ähm mir war das gut. Und ähm.
Ja, aber wirklich äh Polarikologie war immer ein starker Konkurrent. Ich bin dann noch Spitzbergen gewesen und selber in Grönland und so weiter. Wollte das äh machen. Ich habe ja einen Kiel studiert.
Und äh da konnte man eben diese ganzen tollen Sachen auch machen, mit der Meereskunde und diesen Ding,
Ja, aber zur Loge bin ich eben auch. Und äh die Fledermäuse liefen immer mit und dann wird's am Ende dann doch eine Diplomarbeit zum Thema Fledermäuse.
Jetzt ja äh glaube ich, den meisten Leuten Schleswig-Holstein eigentlich eher so als flaches Land äh bekannt, aber wenn ich hier so rausgucke, hier geht ja äh richtig was ab. Also, wir sind hier so direkt am Berg. Was ist das hier für einen Berg.
Genau, wie aus dem Fenster gucken, sehen wir den Segeberger Kalkberg oder im Prinzip das, was von ihm noch übrig ist, der war mal höher
äh ist hier abgebaut worden, das Gestein, das Anhydrid ist als Baumaterial, also als Baukleber dann verarbeitet worden, also gibt's dann. Ähm ja, das ist einer der wenigen Orte hier im
flachen Schleswig-Holstein, wo wirklich festes Gestein ansteht. Und das ist eigentlich auch eine Laune der Natur,
denn ähm im Untergrund, wenn wir jetzt hier runter bohren würden, dann hätten wir hier Steinsalz in der Tiefe. Die norddeutsche Tiefebene ähm hat im Untergrund riesige Mengen Salz,
ähm aus der Zechsteinzeit, da gab's auch schon mal eine sehr heiße Klimaphase, da war der Teil von Deutschland hier,
Teil eines tropischen Flach Meeres, was dann durch diese krasse Klimaerwärmung in der Zechsteinzeit,
vor sich hin verdunstete und das Salz übrig blieb und das liegt hier im Untergrund und dann hatten hatten sich im Laufe der Erdgeschichte, andere,
Ablagerungen darüber,
gelegt und das Ganze geriet unter Druck und dieses Salz der norddeutschen Tiefebene hat jetzt so eine Art plastischen Zustand erreicht, durch dieses schwere Material was drüber liegt und,
ist ja als denn so halt, kann man sich vorstellen, bisschen zähflüssig und an Schwachstellen dieser Erdkruste macht's dann so ein Blubb und so ein Salzdom kommt nach oben.
Geologen würden das jetzt noch etwas dramatischer darstellen, aber ähm es sind halt geologische Zeiträume, das dauert dann ein bisschen bis es dann nach oben kommt, aber,
durch diesen äh Auftrieb äh werden dann die unteren Schichten mit an die Oberfläche gebracht und dann ist oberhalb von so einem Salzdom immer der sogenannte Gipshut. Da sind dann eben die Steine,
aus der Zechsteinzeit da. Und das haben wir hier in Sägeberg, Lüneburg, gibt's das genauso,
und Salztektonik kann auch andere Erdschichten nach oben bringen, beispielsweise in Mönstet, in Jütland, das ist ein bisschen weiter nördlich von hier,
da ist dann die Kreide, also ähnlich wie Rügen, ähm der Kreidefelsen ist dann nach oben gekommen durch Salz.
Und das sind ja alles so Stoffe, die auch ganz gerne mal ausgewaschen werden so über die Zeit. Und dann entstehen Höhlen. Das heißt, hier sind wahrscheinlich auch eine Menge.
Ja, ganz genau. Das ist der, der Grund, warum wir hier in Schleswig-Holstein, in Bad Segeberg, die nördlichste Höhle Deutschlands haben natürliche Höhle eben dieses äh Anhydrid ist sehr gut wasserlöslich und kann ausgewaschen werden.
Und ist dann im Laufe der der äh Erzgeschichte quasi auch ausgewaschen worden, die letzten Auswaschungen dürften,
über die Wässer der Eiszeit abschmelzen. Gletscher passiert sein, aber der dürfte auch vorher äh schon einiges ausgehöhlt worden sein. So haben wir hier also eine,
eine Auslaugungshöhle,
direkt neben dem Fledermauszentrum, die Sägeberger Kalkberghöhle, die man unter, ja, nicht Seiten dann auch als Besucher besichtigen kann. Im Moment haben wir die Öle,
leider geschlossen.
Mhm.
Mir die Gelegenheit auch nochmal auf eine frühere Sendung von mir hier auf diesem Kanal zu verweisen, CAE zwei null eins, hat sich nämlich der Höhlenforschung äh gewidmet, wo ich sogar ernsthaft vorher nochmal äh so richtig im vollen.
Schlatz durch die Höhlen durchgeroppt äh bin. Das.
Musste jetzt auch nicht mehr unbedingt nochmal haben, war, Alex, der aufschlussreich. Und da haben wir irgendwie äh viel über diese Entstehung und äh vor allem auch über die Entdeckung und Erforschung dieser Höhlen,
gesprochen, da steht aber hier wahrscheinlich weniger im Vordergrund, hier geht's um die Fledermäuse, die hier kräftig vertreten sind.
Ja, ganz genau, also Höhenforschung äh findet hier auch statt und hat hier auch stattgefunden. Man hat äh die Höhle im Jahr neunzehnhundertdreizehn entdeckt. Das ist relativ spät. Man hat hier eigentlich schon im Mittelalter angefangen, dieses Gestein abzubauen,
und ähm es gab hier auch mal äh ein ein Kaiser, der hier eine Burg auf diesen Kalkberg äh gebaut hat. Ähm.
Kaiserluther, der Dritte,
und die ist dann im dreißigjährigen Krieg von den Schweden, hier so ein bisschen eingenommen worden und auch äh plattgemacht worden, kann man so salopp sagen. Ähm und im Rahmen dieser äh dieser dieses Burgbaus braucht man natürlich auch einen Burgbrunnen und hat man dann,
kann man auch besichtigen, da gibt's auch den alten Brunnenschacht, wenn wir hier rausgucken, sehen wir die Plattform, wo die Besucher dann von oben in diese.
Brunnenschacht, das Letzte, was von der Burg immer übrig ist von der Siegesburg. Reingucken können. Und da haben die aber genau an der Stelle runtergegraben und lassen die Höhle nicht getroffen haben. Die Höhle ist hier mehr so eine Art Halbkreis äh fächert sich auf, wie so eine Art,
ja, kleines Flussgeld, da kann man sich das vorstellen, das ist eher auf der östlichen Seite, ein schmaler, enger Gang, der sogenannte Südostgang. Ähm,
und dann fächert sich das weiter auf und dann gibt es so größere Auslagungs äh Bereiche mit,
mit Hallen und so weiter, aber es ist insgesamt eine eine kleine Höhle. Und das haben die also im Mittelalter verpasst und erst kurz vorm Ende des der Abbauzeit hier äh in den neunzehnhundertdreißiger Jahren,
äh wurde hier der Bergbau eingestellt, hat man eben neunzehnhundertdreizehn bei Sprengarbeiten die Sägeberger Kalkberghöhle,
ja, angebissen, quasi, das hat man erst gar nicht so gemerkt, die Steinbrucharbeiter, für die waren das jetzt nicht so interessant, aber,
neunzehnhundertdreizehn gehen wir mal zurück, was ist da so passiert? Das ist ja noch,
ja eine ganz andere Zeit gewesen. Also ich habe mal geguckt, was zwar neunzehnhundertdreizehn, da ist der erste Mensch quasi mit einem Flugzeug, mit so einem kleinen Flugzeug über die Alpen geflogen. Das ist neunzehnhundertdreizehn mal so ein richtiger.
Irgendwas so durch die Presse, was da so los war, ne? So und äh in der Schweiz. Und na ja, ist heute für uns alles, kalter Kaffee, jeder, der dann verreist ist schon mal und nochmal in den Süden geflogen ist, der.
Dann müde beim Kaffee mal aus dem Fenster, wenn unten die Alpen vorbeiziehen. Das war vor etwas über hundert Jahren noch ein riesen Ding. Und derzeit ist das hier entdeckt worden und da war alles dezentral. Da hat der Sägeberg hier noch eine Brauerei und äh eine Meierei.
Lehrerausbildung konnte man natürlich jetzt auch nicht ähm so weit weg machen. Das war alles dezentral. Und man hatte hier eben ein, ein Lehrerseminar und da waren junge Leute, die waren dann so,
achtzehn neunzehn und die hatten mitgekriegt.
Und das im Steinbruch irgendwie was los war. Das hatten in ihre Schüler, die hatten den hier auch schon unterrichtet und so erzählt, da ist irgendwie eine richtige Höhle. Das haben die dann ausgecheck,
und sind dann quasi die Erstbefahrer gewesen und der ähm einer davon hat er einen Bruder, der ist am Ende richtig Geologieprofessor geworden.
Karl-Grip. Ja, der war so äh ja.
Begeistert davon, die haben dann hier sind dann unten da, aber kein elektrisches Licht oder irgendwas, man musste da mit Seilen runter, der also die haben dann in der, in der sogenannten Entdeckungshalle natürlich,
äh sind die dann runter. Äh an Seilen, Höhle war Fenster. Ähm man hat dann schon Fledermausknochen gefunden.
Gänge ausgeguckt und hat dann auch, äh, ja, kristalline Erscheinungen gesehen und so weiter und diesen ganzen Höhlenschluff, ne, was denn, die er da am Schlatz geklebt hat,
waren alles noch unberührt. Ja, und das hat die also so äh begeistert und vor allen Dingen auch diesen Karl-Grip, dass der dann wirklich auch am Ende.
Wieder eine kleine Parallele so, der ist dann auch Polarforscher geworden, er hat also äh Gletscherkunde auch viel gemacht und ist auch in Spitzbergen gewesen, hat es angeschaut und so. Und ähm na ja.
Die zur Höhlenentdeckung hat da äh durch die Höhlenentdeckung, hatte auch sehr viel hier zur ähm Entstehungsgeschichte der Sägeberger Kalkberghöhle ähm,
gearbeitet. Aber das sind dann, ist dann auch das äh Ende meines Wissens da, ich bin ja der Biologe hier, nicht der Geologe, aber äh auf jeden Fall ist die Sägeberger Höhle und der Höhenforschern,
und höhlen begeisterten durchaus kleiner Geheimtipp, weil man hier sehr schöne Formation sehen kann und unter Gips und Auslagungshöhlen äh ist hier sehr viel,
klassischen Formen, die man, die in der Literatur beschrieben sind, die dann hier durch Sägeberg gekommen sind. Also ist also unter.
Höhlenfreunden, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Höhlen Nerds. Auf jeden Fall, auch ein echter Geheimtip.
Okay. Ist die groß, also.
Naja, sie ist klein. Das muss man schon sagen. Also wir haben hier, äh, wenn man alle Nebengänge zusammenlegt und alles so hintereinander macht, dann hat man zwei Kilometer lange Höhle, aber da kommt man ja nicht überall rein, das sind ja viele kleine,
und so und wenn wir hier eine Höhlenführung machen, dann sind wir so eine dreiviertel Stunde etwa mit den Leuten da unten, können sich das angucken und so weiter, wird viel erzählt, es gibt natürlich zur Tierwelt einiges, aber auch zur.
Was ich eben erzählt habe, zuhört, zur Geschichte von Segeberg und zur ähm ja Salztektronik und so weiter. Also das gibt's dann alles nochmal in epischer Breite und das können auch unsere äh Höhlenführer, alles viel besser erzählen, als ich das so hier im Schnelldurchgang gemacht habe,
haben da äh sind da richtig toll und kriegen wir immer gute Rückmeldung.
Ja gut, aber es wird auf jeden Fall klar, es gibt einen äh Grund, warum äh hier das ist, was äh hier ist, nämlich das schon eingangs erwähnte äh Fledermauszentrum. Das ist ähm ja, würdest du das beschreiben, so ein.
Anschauungsort und aber auch Forschungsstandor.
Ja, wir sind, wir sind ein Umweltzentrum, eigentlich auch das das einzige Fledermauszentrum dieser Arten in Deutschland. Das ist schon ein kleines,
Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Ähm die Höhle ist ja Winterschlafort für mehr als dreißigtausend Fledermäuse, verschiedene Arten, da kann man ja bestimmt auch noch drauf.
Über dreißigtausend. Ja, ja, wir zählen das mit einer Lichtschranke, das ist also sehr spannend. Ähm und äh dann ist natürlich der.
Berg, Bad Segeberg, nicht nur für Höhenforscher, ein bekannter Ort, sondern für alle Karl-May-Fans, hier neben uns ist ja,
Theaterstadion und da findet ja auch jedes Jahr dieses Jahr nun leider eine traurige Ausnahme äh für die Karl-May-Spiele statt, so.
Ja, um die vierhunderttausend Besucher, ist also richtig eine Erfolgsstory, der will den Westen ist hier gleich nebenan. Ähm und da ist ein bekannter Ort und davon profitieren wir natürlich auch. Also,
Die Fledermäuse kannten diesen Ort schon lange. Also, die Höhlenforscher, was ich eben gesagt habe, die Erstbefahrer hatten ja die äh Fledermausknochen da unten schon gefunden.
Das ist wohl klar, dass hier äh schon einige tausend Jahre se,
nach der Eiszeit, die Fledermäuse hier wieder eingewandert sind in den Norden, die diese natürliche Höhle auch entdeckt haben und immer schon als Winterschlafquartier genutzt haben. Und deswegen ist das eben auch ein natürliches Winterquartier im Vergleich zu äh,
ja, Bunkeranlagen, die man in größeren Städten hat, beispielsweise Berlin oder Hamburg,
oder neueren Anlagen, die dann Kaltenkrieg errichtet wurden und jetzt äh dem Naturschutz übereignet wurden und so.
Ist es was Besonderes, weil das hier eine ganz, ganz große Tradition gibt bei den Fledermäusen, diesen Ort aufzusuchen. Also Fledermäuse sind Traditionalisten, was das.
Aber was macht jetzt das Fledermaus äh Zentrum alle.
Ja, wir wir sind hier genau, weil dieser Ort eben so besonders ist und besonderes Fledermaus vorkommen hat, hatte man sich hier in der Stadt überlegt, auch ähm äh angeregt, auch durch den Naturschutzbund,
doch ein Informationszentrum einzurichten und jetzt äh hat noch vier Etagen, wir haben pro Etage.
Namen haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Noktalis heißt das, genau. Mhm.
Locktales Welt der Fledermäuse, genau. Das Fledermaus Zentrum Bad Segeberg,
ähm ist ein Kunstwort, Nortalis haben wir uns ausgedacht, weil erinnert ein bisschen an an die Nacht ans Lateinische angelegt, angelehnt Nocks und viele Fledermausarten,
heißen so ähnlich, Nücktalus, Nock, Toular, der große Abendsegler kommt hier Deutschland vor, ähm überall,
und äh dann haben wir gedacht, wir müssen uns irgendwas ausdenken, was uns ein bisschen,
ausmacht, dass man's auch bei Google Trends mal findet und so. Und äh das ist dann nockter alles geworden, genau. Und ähm von außen denkt man immer, ist ein bisschen klein, aber wir haben anderthalb Etagen unter der Erde auch, das ist also ein bisschen eingegraben. Im Kino,
und den vier Etagen,
oder in die Lebensräume der Fledermäuse äh dargestellt. Ähm dann haben wir sogar lebende Tiere. Wir haben eine ganze Etage mit ähm Zootieren. Wir haben also eine eine eigene Fledermaushaltung.
Was äh mehr als einhundert tropischen Brillenblattnasenfledermäusen, die essen so Bananen und äh Melonen und so weiter kommen aus Mittel und Südamerika.
Dann haben wir einen zahmen Flughund, das ist Foxive Laterinchen, die wir,
ähm bekommen haben, ursprünglich ist die mal geboren worden, im Tierpark Friedrichsfelde, auch eine kleine Verbindung nach Berlin,
ähm ist dort von der von den Zootierpflegern Pflegerinnen dann von Hand aufgezogen worden, ist dann eine Zwischenzeit in Krefeld gewesen im Zoo und al,
die Flughunde dann irgendwie mal äh ja abgeschafft wurden, kann man sagen, also da gibt's ja immer Wechsel bei den äh Tierbeständen und so weiter, dann sind die nach Tschechien gegangen und da hat dann der,
äh Tierarzt, der seiner Zeit da tätig war. Äh Martin Straube, der hat dann gesagt, Mensch, Foxi, die ist auch so, oder Flatterinchen, wie sie seinerzeit nahe ist, die ist doch ganz zarm und die braucht doch,
eigentlich auch immer jemand zu kuscheln und so, die kann auch jetzt nicht einfach so mit. Da hat er uns gefragt, ob wir sie nicht übernehmen können. Was haben wir denn gemacht? Und äh die macht jetzt hier einen tollen Job, weil wir nicht nur eine Ausstellung sind. Kann ich kann jeder kommen. Wir haben,
geöffnet und haben aber auch Pädagogik, wir haben ganz viele Schulklassen da, das heißt Kinder, Jugendliche,
ähm informieren wir hier über Fledermäuse, die machen eine Höhlenführung und so weiter und da ist natürlich so ein,
ja, zahmer Flughund, groß, die ist ja dreißig Zentimeter so. Großes Tier und Flügelspannweite bis äh ein Meter zwanzig, ein Meter dreißig, wenn die dann so aufmacht. Das toll. Also das ist was Handfestes und,
also ein dolles Tier, ne.
Ja, jetzt hast du ja auch äh ganz passend zu diesem Gespräch auch ein Fledermaus-T-Shirt äh an.
Habe ich mir natürlich extra angezogen, aber ist ja keine Kamera da heute, aber ich dachte, wir.
Sehr.
Batman muss sein. Also.
Genau und das ähm gibt mir sozusagen die Vorlage, äh vielleicht bevor wir auf die Tiere selbst zu sprechen konnten, auch nochmal zu reflektieren, dass ja Fledermäuse.
Zu denen sicherlich nicht die einzigen Tiere sind, aber die so ein, finde ich, einen besonderen kulturellen Status haben bei uns Menschen
Angstkomponenten dabei, ja, die Salze, Vampir, ähm Kultur äh Raum, der da äh über die Jahrzehnte Jahrhunderte äh geschaffen wurde, mit viel Arbeit glauben und was nicht alles
auf der einen Seite, aber dann eben auch solche Popkulturellen,
Aspekte. War das bei dir dann auch so ein Antrieb? Ähm hatte das irgendwie, spielte das irgendwie so eine Rolle, sondern haben Fledermäuse so eine besondere Anziehungskraft. Also ich meine, das treibt sicherlich Leute ja auch hierher an, also
unter anderem, wenn dich bewusst dann äh sicherlich irgendwie unterbewusst, weil sie irgendwie Tiere sind, die ja.
Einerseits uns ähnlich sind, weil's Säugetiere sind, aber dann eben auch die totale äh Ausnahme äh sind.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Also, bei mir persönlich war das ein bisschen anders. Ich habe mal als Jugendlicher mit sechzehn, eine tote Fledermaus gefunden, um Urlaubsreise und ich war immer schon ziemlich, ja, man würde fast sagen, im Biologen naht, also ich,
Biologie immer spannend und habe das immer alles gesammelt und gemacht, auch zum Leitwesen meiner Familie seiner Zeit. Ich habe als nach Hause gebracht, irgendwie ausgebrütet,
vergessen auch und dann schlüpften irgendwelche Dinge, Nachtfalter im Schrank und äh
irgendwelche Dürosophie von Hawaii, die Großen, die ich mal aus der Uni gekriegt hatte, die die brachen sich Bahn und waren dann in der Wohnung unterwegs und irgendwann musste ich dann raus.
Aber deine Eltern haben dich geliebt, nehme ich an.
Ja, na klar, aber ich hatte irgendwann eine klare Ansagen, also das ging dann nicht mehr in der Wohnung. Das musste dann in dem Nebenraum von der Garage, musste das alles laufen. Experimente hieß das. Keine Experimente mehr in der Wohnung. Ähm und da so war ich halt drauf und ja.
Also im Film wärst du dann gebissen worden und äh zu einem Superhelden oder.
Zum Superhelden geworden, ja, das äh so kann das gehen. Ähm.
Bin da nicht gebissen worden, aber diese diese Faszination für die Biologie, die hat sich also durchgezogen, ich wollte das unbedingt werden. Also, ich habe mir ja auch nie andere Gedanken gemacht,
hätte man ja früher auch mal an was anderes denken können, dann wäre einem vielleicht auch einiges ers
geblieben, aber egal, es ist gelaufen, ich bin jetzt hier an diesem Ort gekommen mit äh dem Ansatz und das ist okay. Äh,
er hatte also jetzt keine riesen Batman Comic Sammlung oder sowas in der Richtung, sondern klar über so ein,
Fledermausfund im Urlaub, der dann mit den Schule gegangen ist und dann kriegt ich ein Fledermausbuch dazu und dann fand ich das super spannend und so, zack war ich infiziert, quasi von dem,
Und der Motivation, aber.
Wahrscheinlich Sache schon ein bisschen einfacher, dass irgendwie auch gerade so an äh Jugendliche heranzutragendes Thema.
Klar. Klar und Fledermäuse haben ja auch ganz besondere Anpassungen, die ja auch,
bisschen herausfordern und dieser kulturelle Aspekt, den du jetzt angesprochen hast, der gilt ja hauptsächlich jetzt so für,
die europäische Kultur, da sind Fledermäuse sehr oft mit Tod und Teufel in Verbindung gebracht, ist ja auch klar. Also wenn wir,
Satan und so, das ist das Mittelalter. Stellen wir uns das vor, es gab kein elektrisches Licht, die Leute sind in der Kerze oder eine, äh,
Öllampel durch die Gegend gelaufen und dann gab es halt Tiere, die nachts rauskamen nur nachts, die dann an an Geheimnisvollen Orten in irgendwelchen Gruften lebten oder einen Schloss Ruinen, ja,
oder so und dann wirklich nur nachts unterwegs waren und sich da auch orientieren konnten, ähnlich wie wie Eulen ja auch, die waren ja auch mystische Vögel, da ruft der Eule und so, dann stirbt jemand und so weiter. Also da hatte man sich ja die so, da war die Fantasie ja grenzenlos,
immer so in so dunkle Kanäle rein,
Und das ähm hat sich ja auch erst aufgelöst, diese ganze Geschichte in den neunzehnhundertdreißiger Jahren, als überhaupt mal einer ein Ultraschallmikrofon erfunden hat,
da holen die Fledermäuse ja entzaubert, also ähm.
Ein bisschen weiter vorher gab's ja schon Naturforscher, die sich damit beschäftigt haben, der Sparland Zahn, die zum Beispiel aus Italien, der hat einfach mal Fledermäuse in seine Studierstube da geholt und hat äh,
wollte mal rausfinden, wie die das machen. Wie können die das? Er hat die dann geblendet und in die Ohren verstopft und sie in eine,
Flugraum fliegen lassen, wo er äh Fäden gespannt hatte, wo Glöckchen waren und also sie geblendet hatte. Also.
Schlimmste Tierversuche, ne, ich würde mal heute so nicht machen, äh aber das war mal seiner Zeit so, hat er auch alles so aufgeschrieben, ähm, sind die dann schön da, um die,
Glöckchen, Fäden rumgekurft, nichts passiert, als er in die Ohren verstopft hat.
Sehr nett, hat er einen Wachs reingemacht, ne. Ähm da sind sie dagegen geflogen, klingelten die Glöckchen und dann hat er irgendwie etwas äh konnte er sich das nicht erklären, sie sie macht das mit den Ohren. Also das wusste er dann, aber wie sie's machen konnte, nicht sagen. Und wenn man alte Schulbücher hat.
Neunzehnhundertzehn oder so, dann wird sich da auch um das Thema,
großohrige Fledermaus, er spürt durch den Luftzug irgendwie die Hindernisse und so weiter, wenn man das dann so liest, denkt man auch, ja, ihr wisst es eigentlich gar nicht, ne? Könntet ihr auch nicht wissen. Und dann ist es erst in den neunzehnhundertdreißiger Jahren.
Kommen, das in, in Holland und in den USA, also Niederlanden, USA, fast gleichzeitig Leute, ähm, Federmäuse mal voll Ultraschall-Mikrofon gesetzt haben und so eine.
Relativ leise vor sich hin, zieht eine Fledermaus wurde dann zum Schallmonster.
Sondern den Ultraschall hört. Und das sind natürlich dann die Anpassungen, ähm, die die Fledermäuse, ja, seit Millionen von Jahren haben und super erfolgreich waren. Also, das ist auch einfach die Fledermaus ist einfach ein, ein Erfolgsmodell,
der der Evolution kann man nicht anders sagen, also gilt natürlich für alle Arten, aber bei den Fledermäusen ist ein bisschen so wie beim,
VW Käfer gewesen. Der ist einmal so, das Modell entwickelt. Alle Fledermäuse sind ja relativ ähnlich und schon sehr früh in der Evolution,
auch so ausgeprägt, wie wir das heute sehen. Da kann man beispielsweise Fossilien aus der grobe Messe sich anschauen, die sind im Prinzip.
Der Biologe sieht da noch ein paar Unterschiede, aber im Prinzip sind die so, äh wie wir heute unsere Fledermäuse auch kennen und die haben schon das gemacht, was die Fledermäuse heute auch tun,
ken gejagt und so weiter. Ähm und sind einfach einmal erfunden worden in der Evolution. Vor.
Also die Fledermäuse von vor fünfundfünfzig Millionen Jahren sind schon fast so ähnlich wie die heute. Also ist gar kein Problem. Sie sind einmal erfunden und dann divers.
Also Fledermäuse sind so ein bisschen in der selben Kiste wie so Schildkröten und Krokodile und so, die halten ja auch schon äh erstaunlich lange äh durch.
Ja, gut, Säugetiere sind noch nicht so lange, wie jetzt die Reptilien auf dem Plan, aber.
Ja, aber die sich ja dann auch nicht mehr weiter verändert haben, ne? Also wohl der Anpassung so, aber zur Evolution kommen wir vielleicht gleich. Ich wollte nochmal kurz dieses kulturelle nochmal auskosten. Ähm, gerade was sozusagen dieses Vampir-Ding äh betrifft. Es ist ja auch ähm
Also es gibt ja äh, ich es richtig sehe, eine spezielle Fledermaus,
Unterart äh diese Vampir äh Fledermäuse, die sozusagen auch noch genauso heißen. Ähm aber glaube ich, in Europa gar nicht mal so äh verbreitet äh sind in der Form,
wo kam denn das äh Herrn? Warum hat das die Leute so beschäftig.
Ja, ich habe meine Vampirfledermaus hier auf dem Schreibtisch gestellt und zwar das Skelett einer Vampirfleder, wo ich wusste, also es gibt ja eigentlich kein Interview, wo nicht auch die Vapierfledermaus bei irgen,
ist ja klar, habe ich hier mitgebracht, also ist ja so ein kleiner Kandidat, das ist der sogenannte gemeine Vampir, also nicht, weil er jetzt so unheimlich niederträchtig ist, sondern weil es also der,
der normale Vampir ist, es gibt drei verschiedene Vampirfledermausarten, die kommen alle in Mittel und Südamerika vor, in Europa, dem Rest der Welt gibt's keine.
Blutfressenden Fledermäuse. Es gab ähm noch eine weitere Vampirfledermausart, die hatte den schönen Namen,
des Modus Dracula. Die war dann noch etwas größer als dieser normale Vampir. Also wir sehen jetzt hier so etwa einen acht Zentimeter großes Tier, also.
Klein, ne? Und die war dann so sechzehn Zentimeter groß, da muss jetzt auch keiner denken, dann verdunkelt sich die Sonne, wenn jetzt der Dracula Vampir, der ausgestorbene irgendwo am Himmel fliegt, nein, das waren kleine Tiere,
ähm aber bisschen ungerecht ist es, weil ähm im Prinzip ähm dieser Vampirismus schon,
vor der Entdeckung dieser Fledermäuse in Südamerika ja aufkam, also es ist ja eine mittelalterliche Geschichte, es ist wieder gehen, also das Auferstehen von,
von von Toten, die dann irgendwie sich an lebendigen Rechen und so weiter. Man wusste ja nicht, wie, wie ähm.
Ja, der Ablauf so nach dem Tod war und man hat dann irgendwann mal angefangen, Leute auszugraben, mal zu gucken, was passiert,
und dann waren die irgendwie gar nicht so nach einer gewissen Zeit gar nicht so vergangen, wie man sich das vielleicht vorgestellt hatte. Das lag daran, dass die unter Luftabschlusslagen irgendwo und ja, die waren frischer, als man das erwartet hatte und dann dachte man, naja, und dann passierten irgendwelche Dinge in Dörfern.
Na ja, wer kann da Schuld sein? Natürlich die Verstorbenen, die immer schon vielleicht mal ein bisschen.
Schlecht drauf waren und die haben sich da jetzt gerecht. Also solche Ideen sind dadurch gewabert. Und ähm dann passte das natürlich. Und das interessante war, ähm ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen makaber, aber wenn man dann,
so in seinem Sag liegt und da eingegraben ist, dann kommen ja äh,
Flüssigkeiten, die vielleicht aus dem Mund laufen und so war dann in der Blutfaden, auch aus dem Mund gekommen und so hatte dann die Fantasie freien Lauf, dass sich die, die Untoten quasi noch an dem Blut der
der lebendigen ähm Leben halten und so weiter. Also bin da jetzt kein äh Vampirismus-Experte, das möge man mir nachsehen. Ich bin da mehr der Naturwissenschaftler, aber diese.
Aber es war nicht ursächlich mit den Pleder.
Genau, man hat die dann danach benannt, weil es wirklich, man feststellte, ein Südamerika gibt es eben diese drei äh Vampirfledermausarten aktuell,
ausschließlich von Blut ernähr,
Also das ist eine sehr spezielle Ernährungsform und sehr gut angepasst, wenn man sich jetzt hier das kleine Skelett anschaut, dann sieht man auch vorne die scharfen Zähne, also es ist nicht so, dass äh wir das oft dargestellt wird, dass diese,
diese Vampirfledermaus, irgendwelche hohlen Zähne hätte und dann die Ecksähne in denen das Opfer schlägt und dann durch die äh durch den Zahnkanal da das Blut einsaugt. Nein, die haben Rasiermesserschafe, Zähne,
äh die, wie eine Schere funktionieren, so ineinander greifen.
Eigentlich sogar noch besser. Sie würden, wenn ein Vampirfledermaus beißt, dann kneift sie erst die Haut zusammen, weil,
Zahnleisten erst so eine kleine Hautdelle machen. Und wenn sie dann weiter beißt, dann schürft sie quasi die Oberhaut ab, so dass das Ganze die Haut so beschädigt ist, dass ähm.
Blutkapillarsystem ordentlich ähm blutet. Also eine Schürfwunde machen die, genau. Und dann haben sie sogar noch ähm,
Hornplättchen auf der Zungenspitze, mit der stochern sie dann in dieser Wunde rum und haben eine gespaltene Unterlippe, sodass sie da andocken können und dann diesen Blutfluss so richtig in sich reinlaufen lassen kö,
und das ist schon sehr toll. Also wir sind super angepasst und wenn jetzt eine Fledermaus so eine Vampirfledermaus, beispielsweise beim Rind oder so, ähm schlafen im Rind, da anzapft, dann will die ja eigentlich nicht die ganze Flüssigkeit.
Die haben also die eine der besten Nierenleistungen überhaupt bei Säugetieren, ähm weil diese ganze Flüssigkeit sofort abgetrennt wird vom Rest, die wollen ja eigentlich die roten weißen Blutkörperchen, also diese ganze.
Nährstoffgehalt da rausholen, eine ganze Energie, aber die Flüssigkeit brauchen sie nicht. Also ein Vampir, der frisst, der tankt vorne rein und hinten macht er schon Pipi,
und der ist dann so vollgelaufen,
eher schon in dem Moment. Ähm das kommt nicht selten vor. Und äh der ist dann so vollgelaufen, dass er dann erstmal zu Fuß weggeht, bis dann sozusagen das Ganze ähm schon die Spreu vom Weizen getrennt ist.
Durch durch.
Gefiltert durch die Niere. Also das ist toll. Und eine Sache noch, das muss man einfach erwähnen. Man denkt immer so, dass es total gemein fließt, die fressen Blut und so.
Die sind so spezialisiert, dass wenn die sechsunddreißig Stunden nichts gefressen haben, sterben die. Das ist wirklich krass. Die brauchen das so,
und deswegen sind Vampirfledermäuse untereinander total sozial verträglich. Da kann sich keiner leisten auf deutsch gesagten Arschloch zu sein, wenn der keine Freunde hat, dann steppt er, weil er nicht sicher sein kann, dass er alle sechsunddreißig Stunden mal zu einer Mahlzeit komm.
Jetzt kommt der Clou, die sind also in Freundschaftsverbänden zusammen, wir leben in Gruppen, haben da ihre Kumpels. Und wenn mal einer nicht zum Zuge kommt, dann kann der seinen Kumpel anbetteln und der gibt ihm dann auch als Erwachsenstier,
bisschen was von seiner Nahrung ab, so eine Art Notration, dass der durchkommt. Und wer sich da mies verhält, der wird von der Evolution,
Vampirfledermäusen krass aussortiert. Da gibt's einfach nur nette Leute, bei den Vampirflederbäumen. Also das macht sie vielleicht auch etwas sympathischer dann an der.
Weil ähm heißt das, dass die Gruppe für die äh Fledermäuse auch eine eine übergeordnete Bedeutung hat, also sind sie sozusagen auch als Gruppe stärker oder ist es hier wirklich sehr erhalten der Spezis, kann man das irgendwie.
Einsortier.
Ja, kann man auf jeden Fall ist es bei äh der Menge der Fledermäuse, die es gibt. Es gibt ja äh weit über tausend verschiedene Fledermausarten. Ich glaube, tausendvierhundert verschiedene jetzt mittlerweile. Werde auch mal neu entde,
ist es so, dass er die Paar die Fledermaus wie bei Vögeln, Männchen, Weibchen und Nest oder so. Ähm das ist eher die Ausnahme. Da gibt's eigentlich immer Gru,
Also es ist eigentlich äh so, dass die von Kleingruppen, zu Haaren, Strukturen.
Äh so dann ihre auch sogenannte Wochenstuben bilden. Das heißt, die Weibchen, Schwestern und Tanten und so weiter. Die bringen alle in.
Gruppe ihre ihre Jung zur Welt. Ähm und das kann bis hin zu einigen Millionen Individuen in Höhlen, beispielsweise.
Kommen also Afrika,
Amerika, Südamerika, da gibt's Höhlen mit Millionen von Fledermäusen. Das hat nochmal ausgerechnet, da könnte es sind ein, da würden dann in so einer Höhle an Biomasse so äh drei bis fünf Blauwale an an Gewicht.
Ich wollt's gerade einen Elefanten um.
Ja, ja, ja, aber ja, das könnten wir auch. Ich glaube, dreißig Elefanten sein blau, weil ich müsste da nachgucken, das sind die Klassik, klassischen Bilder, aber bitte nagelt mich da jetzt nicht fest, dass.
Aber wir können auch die Elefantenwährung leben.
Ja, okay, nee, passt.
Auf jeden Fall spannend, also riesige Tieransammlung.
Aber sie agieren ja nicht als als Gruppe, sondern sie sind ja dann eigentlich immer einzeln unterwegs.
Ja, also die Rudeljagd, der Fledermäuse ist nicht bekannt. Also, das ist eher, dass sie ähm,
genau wie du sagst, alleine unterwegs sind, aber natürlich auch schon so ein bisschen drauf hören, was äh macht der andere und vielleicht kriegen sie auch raus, wenn einer eine gute Nahrungs äh Ressource gefunden hat, so da wird gefressen, dass das die neugierig macht. Also das ist auf jeden Fall so.
Sowie die Bienen.
Jetzt war schon fast äh zu viel äh in den Bereich eingestiegen, da kommt man ja auf jeden Fall noch zu. Vielleicht um nochmal die Kulturwelle äh Klammer ähm zu schließen. Also ich fasse nochmal kurz zusammen. Äh.
Erst als man diese Vampirfledermäuse gefunden äh und entdeckt hat, wie sie sich ernähren.
Haben sie diesen Namen übergestülpt bekommen, also es ging sozusagen in diese Richtung. Dieses Drakulär kam dann genau woher.
Estra Kollege, ähm ja, der, der ist gefunden worden, als Skelet
Man hat in Südamerika ausgrabung gemacht in Höhlen und hat dann einen viel größeren Vampir, eine größere Vampirfledermaus oder deren Reste gefunden. Und das hängt damit zusammen, dass in äh Südamerika ähm,
auch äh in der Vergangenheit größere Säugetiere gelebt haben. Also da waren einfach größere Säugetiere unterwegs und die ähm.
Waren auch, konnten dann eben auch größere Vampirfledermäuse ernähren. Die sind dann halt ausgestorben, diese Fauna und mit ihnen auch die.
Dracula Vampirfledermaus, die dann den Namen auch d.
Dracula heißt eigentlich heißt es Drachen oder also es ist die größer.
Ja, das ist einfach ein Namen, äh, das ist eigentlich ja die, äh, so ein, ein, ähm, Herrscher in Rumänien gewesen,
der äh relativ äh Blutrundstich äh agiert hat. Das ist auch eine eine schlimme Geschichte. Kann man sich im Fledermauszentrum hier auch angucken bei uns. Wir haben natürlich was zu Dracula gemacht. Also der Vla.
Von dem kommt der Name sozusagen. Okay.
Kommt dann an, von Wlat Dracool. Der hat ähm in äh sieben Bürgen äh in Rumänien seiner Zeit, äh, das Abendland verteidigt gegen äh die Türken. Und hat das sehr drakonisch gemacht, indem man also seine,
Gefangenen auf Fehler aufgespießt hat. Gibt verehrt hat. So und der war ziemlich durchgeknallt, kann man sagen.
Äh sich da beide noch äh bewirken lassen und sich das angeguckt, wie Leute da massakriert wurden. Also äh,
keine tolle Sache, so insgesamt, aber äh,
daher kam das und ähm spielt halt eine Rolle und das hat dann natürlich der in seinem Buch Dracula eben auch verarbeitet, diese historische Gestalt und hat das darum dann so ein bisschen rumgestrick,
das Ganze wollte es eigentlich äh,
deiner Zeit mal in Österreich spielen lassen, hat dann seinen Verlag gesagt, er kann's nicht machen. Also da muss ja was anderes ausdenken, ist doch eigentlich nicht gut. Und da ist er auf Rumänien und äh diese diese Geschichte dann gekommen. Und so, so kam das, also, dass er eben diese, na ja,
diese Gruselgeschichten waren eine Zeit lang mal sehr in, in.
Okay, ich habe sie nochmal kurz nachgeschlagen, also Drakole ähm ist quasi von ihm ein Beinname gewesen, Sohn des Drachens.
Okay, so ein Sohn des Drachens. Okay, da hatte ich das richtig in Erinnerung. Okay, also und der hat dann sozusagen, aber wie kam's denn dann sozusagen von ihm zur Fledermaus? Also, wie ist.
Na ja, zu Logen sind da ja auch nicht ganz äh unbelesen und äh müssen ja nun auch,
äh wenn man so einen Namen für ein Tier vergibt, dann muss man ja auch irgendwie etwas äh das in den Namen so reinbauen, dass es vielleicht auch das Tier schon ein bisschen beschreibt.
Optimal. Und na ja, nun wusste man, dass diese Vampirfledermäuse ähm Blut trinken und hat sie dann eben ähm.
Äh sozusagen der Einkategorisiert und du war das der größte bekannte äh Vampir, den man gefunden hat, Vampirfledermaus, dann hat man sich gesagt, naja, dann nennen wir den eben,
des Modus Dracula.
Weil der so besonders Blutrünstig.
Weil er besonders groß war und fossil und dann eben der der Dracula so ähm ne, der Name war noch frei.
Und das Wort Vampir selber, also dieser Vampirismus, den da den Toten unverwesten, äh, unterstellt wurde. Das ist dann auch eine südamerikanische Erfindung.
Nee, das gibt's auch. Also es ist auch was aus dem äh aus dem Mittelalter im Prinzip. Irgendwie.
Ja, das war, man konnte sich das nicht erklären,
dass die Verwesung nicht so stattfindet, wie man sich das eigentlich gedacht hat. War ja auch nicht, weil ich gar nicht erlaubt. Also, sollte sich das ja gar nicht angucken. Also, ist ja die Medizin ja auch heimlich,
äh vorangekommen, dass man dann irgendwo im dunklen, nachts dann irgendwelche Leichen zerlegt hat, um überhaupt mal zu lernen, wie, wie der menschliche Organismus funktion.
Das ging ja gar nicht anders.
Gut, ähm dann gehen wir mal ein bisschen mehr in die Biologie, bevor wir da vielleicht äh tiefer einsteigen, denke ich, ist vielleicht nochmal ganz
äh brauchbar ein wenig zur logische ähm Kategorisierungsgrundkenntnisse zu erfassen, weil was ja schon gesagt, es gibt enorm viele Arten, also ich hatte jetzt tausend gelesen, du saß tausendvierhundert, also sehr viele einzelne,
Fledermausarten, die so einen eigenen Namen tragen und die
irgendeiner Form durch irgendwelche Merkmale äh sich unterscheiden von den anderen, auch wenn sie alle irgendwie im Wesentlichen Fledermäuse äh sind. Jetzt gibt's ja da Ordnung und Karton und so weiter. Wie weit müssen wir da jetzt äh reinschauen, um da irgendwie die Zusammenhänge noch.
Ja, das ist eigentlich gar nicht so so schwierig. Äh,
Biologen ordnen natürlich alles und muss alles einen Namen haben und dann guckt man sich natürlich an, wer ist mit wem verwandt und wie hängen diese Verwandtschaften zusammen? Und da kommt man zu größeren Einheiten und so und wir können ja eigentlich mal zu überlegen
äh können ja mal die Wirbeltiere uns anschauen, da haben wir äh Fische, Amphibien, Reptilien, Vögel.
Säugetiere und Fledermäuse sind Säugetiere, sie bekommen lebende Junge und ernähren diese mit mit Milch, das ist eben das äh.
Äh Kriterium der der Säugetiere.
Und innerhalb dieser Säugetiere gibt es äh verschiedene Gruppen, also Ordnung, da gibt's die Wale, die Huftiere, die Nagetiere und die Fledertiere und äh nach den Nagetieren sind die Fledertiere eben die Gruppe,
den meisten Arten, also die große Diversität eben äh aufweisen und,
auch äh eine große Verbreitung global haben. Fledertiere kommen im Prinzip auf allen Kontinenten vor, mit Ausnahme der Antarktis, da ist zu kalt. Also Polargebiete werden sowieso nicht so
gerne besiedelt von Fledermäusen, nichtsdestotrotz gibt es, äh, beispielsweise die Nordfledermaus hier in Europa, die auch,
noch das Polarkreises, zumindestens in der Polarnacht dann mal vorkommt. Ähm aber die Haupt äh Verbreitungen sind eben die tropischen und subtropischen,
äh Gebiete der Erde.
Dann äh gibt es noch zwei große Untergruppen, kann man so sagen, jetzt erstmal klassischerweise ähm die Flughunde äh und.
Kleinfledermäuse. Man kann das auch ein bisschen anders äh auf kurisieren, aber das ist vielleicht das, was jetzt erstmal so besonders,
eindringlich ist und greifbar während nämlich die Flughunde ähm insgesamt alle etwas äh größer sind, also gibt's auch nicht so viele Arten von, die äh in der sogenannten alten Welt leben, also in Afrika, Asien und Australien,
ähm große Augen haben und eigentlich kein Ultraschall im klassischen Sinne benutzen. Es gibt wenige Flughunde, die so eine Art Zungenschnalzen machen,
der ägyptische Flughund, die können sich dann in Höhlen auch orientieren im Dunkeln, aber das machen sie ein bisschen anders, nicht mit Kehlkopf, sondern die machen so.
Zungenschnalzen, so Doppelklicks und können an den Echos dann auch erkennen, was los ist.
Aber eigentlich nicht. Die haben die Flugkunde sowas nicht. Die gucken eben mit den Augen, haben sehr lange Schnauzen, können sehr, sehr gut riechen. Das sind ja äh Obstesser quasi, Frucht, Fresser und Pollenfresser. Ä.
Leben auch nur in Ausnahmefällen in Höhlen, normalerweise hängen die dann so frei, in Bäumen rum, große Kolonien auch. Ähm.
Ganze mit den Fliesermäusen zusammen in eine.
Genau, sie haben Flug heute in in die Ordnung. Das sind also zwei genau zu den Fledertieren. Haben auch,
genauso aufgebaut, ein bisschen anders äh vom Flügelaufbau, aber im Prinzip ist es das glei.
Und dann gibt's die die ähm klassischen Fledermäuse, die ähm.
Weltweit vorkommen, die allermeisten sind Insektenfresser, aber da gibt's dann eben auch sehr spezielle Anpassungen bei der Ernährung von von Fledermäusen, wenn sie nicht also und auch graduelle Abstufung,
da hatten eben ja schon die Blutfressenden,
drei Vampirfledermausarten erwähnt, dann gibt es welche, die sich speziell auf die Jagd von anderen Wirbeltieren spezialisiert haben, da gibt's froschfressende Fledermäuse, Fischende, Ledermäuse beispielsweise.
Dann aber auch die große Gruppe bei den Fledermäusen, sind die Vegetarier, die dann äh Früchte fressen, kann man sich auch vorstellen, dass das jetzt in Mitteleuropa nicht ganzjährig durchträgt. Da muss man dann in andere Gebiete, wo viel ähm fruchtende,
Pflanzen da sind, wie den tropischen Bereichen, mit Amerika, äh Afrika. Und die spielen eine große Rolle, gerade auch für den tropischen Regenwald, also gerade Fruchtfressen, Fledermäuse, ähm, die dann.
Ähm die Samen auch verbreiten und dann auch wieder irgendwelche äh Kahlstellen ähm die durch Windbruch natürlicherweise entstehen, aber jetzt,
weiß nicht, ob sie gegen die Abholzung des brasilianischen Regenwalds gegen anfressen können. Das, da habe ich ja meine Zweifel, ähm, dann eben zur Wiederbewaldung, zur Aufrostung äh beitragen und dann gibt es eben auch Pollin fressende Fledermäuse.
Wie machen die denn das? Also wie, wodurch tragen sie denn diese Samen weiter? Naja, die Fressen halt die ganze Frucht. Ach so.
Naja, die fressen halt die ganze Frucht. Und dann und dann fliegen sie halt rum und dann äh gibt's dann sozusagen gleich eine,
eine kleine Düngermenge dazu und dann äh manche Samen äh brauchen auch die Darmpassage quasi. Die werden erst aktiviert, wenn sie durch den,
Darm, beispielsweise einer Fledermaus durchgegangen sind. Wenn bestimmte Enzyme angeregt und so und dann geht die Keimung erst los. Also, das gibt ja auch bei Pflanzen dolle Anpassung, andere brauchen Frost, sonst geht's nicht los, aber die äh einige tropische Pflanzen eben die Darmpassage,
durch einen Vogel oder eine Fledermaus dann. So, das spielt spielt eine wichtige Rolle. Und ähm beispielsweise werden auch bestimmte äh Pflanzen.
Von Fledermäusen bestäub.
Also der Tequila Kaktus beispielsweise, für den kleinen Tequila trinken kann, wenn die Fledermäuse, die nicht bestäuben würden oder die äh die Freunde von äh in der Kosmetik,
Share Butter Baum aus Westafrika wird auch stark durch klein kleine Flughunde bestäubt, also spielt eine große Rolle, Bananen, beispielsweise werden auch bestäubte Fledermäuse, also da gibt's eine ganze.
Interessante Palette von ökologischen Zusammenhängen, die wir, wenn wir einfach so ins Regal greifen oder irgendwas rausnehmen, gar nicht so merken, dass da die Fledermäuse eine wichtige.
Teilweise entscheidende Rolle spielen dafür, dass wir auch so ein Produkt haben.
Mhm. Interessant. Okay, also wir haben jetzt diese Ordnung der Fleder äh Tiere, das teilt sich auf in die Flederhunde, das nur weniger und dann die Fledermäuse, das ist dann die ähm wie nennt man das dann da drunter? Also.
So Unterordnung nennen. Das ist heutzutage ein bisschen anders eingeteilt, weil die äh
äh Genetiker auch nochmal nachgeguckt haben und äh auch äh andere Merkmale herangezogen haben, so dass wir äh da eine zu einer leicht anderen Kategorisierung gekommen sind. Da gehören dann beispielsweise die,
ähm,
Hufeisennasen, Fledermäuse noch etwas enger zu den Flughunden dazu. Das ist jetzt aber äh nicht ganz so einsichtig quasi, das kann man von außen nicht so erkennen, zumal die Hufeisennasen, Fledermäuse, eine sehr spezielle,
Form der Echoorientierung haben. Das ist auch äußerst spannend. Die hätte ich das kurz an der Stelle erwähnen darf, die ähm die machen sozusagen konstant, frequente Laute, das heißt,
Ja, wir machen ja hier auch so eine Adradiosendung. Äh, wenn man Radio hört, dann ähm.
Stellt meiner Sendefrequenz ein. Das ist seiner kein Ultraschall, ist kein Schal, sondern,
magnetische Welle, aber man hat dann irgendwie was weiß ich, neunundneunzig Komma sieben oder irgendwas eingestellt. Und so eine äh Frequenz senden dann auch Rufeisennasenfledermäuse.
Trägerfrequenz, lange Signale und das Echo, was dann wieder kommt,
das wird durch Störgeräusche gekennzeichnet. Wenn jetzt also so ein Echo Peilstrahl einer Hufeisennase äh ein fliegendes Insekt trifft, dann wirft das fliegende Insekten Echo zurück,
und zwar genau in dieser Flügelschlagfrequenz dieses,
Falters beispielsweise und dann kann aber die Hufeisennasenfledermaus erkennen. Ah, das ist dieser schmackhafte Falter, den hole ich mir jetzt. Also die sitzen dann irgendwo an so einer äh an so einem Ästchen, an ihrem Fangplatz oder Sitzwarte, Hangwarte quasi,
Orten in die Umgebung und wenn dann Falter vorbeifliegt, wissen sie genau, den hole ich mir, der schmeckt aber gut, weil der diese,
Geräusche halt so macht. Und sie können sogar im Flug, können auch im Flug natürlich Echo Ordnung machen und haben ja eine Eigengeschwindigkei.
Und sie können dann ihre Echofrequenz soweit absinken, das immer.
Echo, also die die Sendefrequenz soweit absenken, dass immer das Echo in der gleichen Frequenz zurückkommt, die sie brauchen, beispielsweise einundachtzig oder zweiundachtzig Kiloherz,
ähm,
weil sie da am besten hören können und diese äh Echos am besten auseinander halten können. Das heißt, die können den Doppelereffekt kompensieren. Doppel-Effekt kennt jeder, der mal an der Straße gestanden hat, einen Motorrad kommt vorbei,
oder Tütatal, wird der Ton erst hoch, mit dem Motorrad und wenn's dich dann entfernt,
So, das ist der Doppeleffekt. Und das können die kompensieren. Double-Effekt, Kompensation bei Hufeisennas.
Das ist also eine tolle Sache. Und ja, diese ganze Ultraschall äh und Orientierung bei Fledertieren, ist ein riesen Forschungsgebie.
Ja, da wollte ich jetzt eigentlich auch, äh, gleich nochmal drauf zu sprechen, kommen vielleicht kurz, sind wir ähm mit dieser Klassifikation, äh, nur um so ein grobes Verständnis zu haben, wie weit sich dieses ganze Feld auffächert, äh, soweit äh, durch
so als jetzt verschiedene Hauptgruppen von Fledermäusen genannt. Also welche Hauptgruppen gilt es generell zu unterscheiden.
Ach so, ja, wir haben jetzt ja dann, wenn wir noch äh die Klassifizierung weiter machen, haben wir diese Säugetierordnung und dann werden,
unterhalb dieser dieser Ordnung gibt's dann Familien. Das sind die sozusagen wird das immer weiter aufge,
splittet, also Fledermaus Familie, da gibt's in Europa beispielsweise die glatt Nasenfledermäuse,
So, die sind dann alle, haben alle ähnliche Merkmale im Vergleich zu den Hufeisennasen, Fledermäusen, da ist der Name schon Programm, da ist die Nase so wie so ein kleines Hufeisen geformt und die senden den Ultraschall eben auch durch die,
Nase aus. Während die Glattnasen, dass durchs Maul aussenden und die haben ja mehr wie so eine Mäuseschnauze, ähm so ein klassische Tierschnauze werden die Hufeisen,
Nasen schon vom Gesicht ja sehr auffällig sind. So. Und da können wir jetzt verschiedenste Fledermausfamilien,
ähm anfühlende Bulldog-Fledermäuse und so weiter. Also ähm da hat der äh, es hat die Zologie dann eben diese Kategorisierung vorgenommen und äh so kann man dann innerhalb dieser Familien.
Und auch einzelne Gattungen, unter Gruppen feststellen und das sind dann immer weitere Merkmale, wo man dann am Ende so eine Art Bestimmungsschlüssel auch draus machen kann, wenn man dann draußen im Feld steht, für Europa ist es dann auch einigermaßen übersichtlich, gibt's auch ein paar.
Spezialitäten, wo man dann auch hingucken muss, was haben wir denn jetzt da gerade gefangen, wenn wir jetzt Fledermäuse im Freiland mal fangen und anschauen,
was natürlich dann je mehr Arten vorkommen, kannst im Äquator Bereich dann haben auf einem Quadratkilometer über hundert verschiedene Fledermausarten vorkommen können,
Das ist natürlich hier, wenn du denkst, Schleswig-Holstein, können fünfzehn verschiedene Fledermausarten vorkommen. Und dann hast du ein Quadratkilometer.
Äh im am Äquator irgendwo in der, in Afrika, im äh Regenwald oder in äh mittelamerika.
Dann kannst du auch mit hundert Arten rechnen, die du da fangen könntest, theoretisch. Ist natürlich was unterschiedliches. Also musst du schon genau gucken, was du da machst. Und manche Arten sind so spitz so eng verwandt, dass da am Ende.
Lieber nochmal ein Genetiker äh draufguckt, aber versierte Freilandbiologen können auch sehr gut.
Wie viel Familien müssen wir so grob unterscheiden? Dann bin ich auch durch, glaube ich, mit dieser äh Abstraktion, also ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen.
Oha, ja.
Die richtigen Fragen.
Das das ist das sind die richtigen Fragen. Also da erwischt mich jetzt so ein bisschen ähm.
In Ordnung. Zehn, hundert, tausend.
Nein, da sind da sind wir eher mit äh mit äh einigen Dutzend dabei. Also es ist nichts.
Viel, das können wir aber gleich nochmal klären, das soll ich hier zwischendurch nochmal raus. Das nee, das äh das lässt wieder keine Ruhe. Da hast du mir jetzt echt eine, am wohnen Punkt erwisch.
Okay. Vielleicht kannst du ja nebenbei kurz mal sagen.
Ich gucke das mal nach und dann werfe ich das nochmal hier in die Diskus.
So rein in Deutschland haben wir wie viele äh Arten ungefähr auf.
Ungefähr fünfundfünfundzwanzig.
Fünfundzwanzig. Okay, das ist ja im Vergleich dann zu der weltweiten Geschichte sehr äh spärlich, aber man schon gehört. So, die Tropen sind da einfach vielfältiger, das sind sie ja ohnehin. Und äh ja, klar, da jetzt.
Wahrscheinlich mehr.
Ausprägungsfreiheit, wie man sich denn jetzt äh wovon äh ernährt. Wir hatten das ja schon Früchte immer da, das funktioniert. Und hier muss man sich dann eben dann doch schon relativ klares Profil äh zulegen, um dann äh entsprechende Überlebensstrategie zu haben.
Und hast die Zahl jetzt.
Ja, ich habe das jetzt hier nochmal rausgesucht. Äh es sind etwa zwanzig verschiedene äh Familien, die ich jetzt hier sehen kann.
Mhm, okay. Dann wird es ja schon gerade angesprochen haben. Was so eine der.
Interessantesten Merkmale ist, ist diese ganze Kommunikation und natürlich damit auch verbunden, die ganze Navigation.
Weiß nicht, kann man gewisserhin sich so in einen Topf äh werfen.
Also die Gliedermäuse sind in der Lage, aber das machen wir auch nicht, machen das alle mit dem Ultraschall, außer den Flughafen meine ich jetzt.
Ja, ganz genau.
Okay, also Ultraschall ist sozusagen generell das Zeichen, du bist eine Fledermaus. So, wenn du Fledermaus dann auch Ultraschall, aber.
Diese hohen Frequenzen werden nicht immer auf die selbe Art und Weise erzeugt, sondern die einen machen das mit der Nase und die anderen machen's im Mund.
Also die Erzeugung findet bei allen Arten im Kehlkopf statt. Das ist auch wie auch unsere Sprache jetzt erzeugen. Das ist der.
Dann muss natürlich ein gewisser äh Druck erzeugt werden, weil der Schalldruck von dem Ultraschall, der der Schall muss ja weit tragen,
und das,
Das ist, das unterscheidet eben die Fledermäuse von von anderen Säugern eben, auch von uns und da kann eben Schalldruck erzeugt werden, bei Fledermäusen, beispielsweise, dem großen Abendsegler, Nüptalas Nock, den wir vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt hatten,
der ist dann so stark wie im Presslufthammer. Der Schalldruck. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass dieser Ultraschall so etwa hundert Meter weit reicht.
Ja, der kann also fünfzig Meter vorausschauen.
Äh das ist natürlich auch sehr laut. Aber zum Glück hören wir den ja nicht, weil oberhalb der menschlichen Hörgrenze ruft, das ist ja auch das die Definition von Ultraschall,
eben oberhalb dessen, was Menschen hören können. Wir können etwa in jungen Jahren bis achtzehn Kiloherz hören. Hunde noch etwas höher. Kann man die Hundepfeife eben auch erwähnen, der.
Kannst du pfeifen und hörst das nicht selber, aber der Hund hört's noch. Ähm so und ähm so ein Abendsegler, den kannst du dann, wenn du so ein Gerät hast und Ultraschalldetektor mit dem dann äh solche Fledermäuse auch wahrgenommen werden können und.
Rufe von denen eben sehr, sehr weit in der Landschaft hören. Das bedeutet aber auch, dass gerade die Arten, die besonders laut rufen, ähm natürlich auch.
Weit vorausschauen können. Und das kann man ja eigentlich nur im freien Luftrau.
Genau eine sehr interessante, spannende Einmischung, verschiedene Fledermausarten,
in ihren Lebensraum, der große Abendsegler fliegt eben sehr, sehr hoch und kann dann sehr weit vorausschauen, aber der Ultraschall, den er nutzt, der ist gar nicht so ultra, der ist nämlich quasi gerade so,
zwischen zwanzig und äh zweiundzwanzig Kiloherz, also so gerade so Ultraschall. Ähm weil natürlich dieser relativ tiefe Ultraschall,
dann auch sehr weit trägt. Wir wissen alle, hatten eben das Beispiel Straße, wir stehen in der Straße, Commotorrad vorbei, jetzt kommt kein Motorrad vorbei, jetzt kommt ein getunter Manta von früher vorbei, mit einer Soundanlage drin, das ist dann die ähm.
Die Tieftöne und die Bässe, die man hört. Die Hochtöne war meistens nicht, weil die Tiefenfrequenzen weitergetragen werden, als die Hohen und der.
Hohen Luftraum jagende Abendsegler und alle anderen Arten weltweit im hohen Luftraum jagen, nutzen, tiefen Ultraschall, um weit vorauszuschauen, der dann aber,
eben auch nur relativ große Insekten abbilden kann. Der kriegt jetzt einen einen Echo von der kleinen Mücke, nicht unbedingt mit, aber von Mistk.
Das kriegt ihr dann mit. So und das andere Extrem, das sind die sogenannten Flüsterfledermäuse, flüster so nah, Fledermäuse, die.
Eben nicht im hohen Luftraum jagen, sondern ganz eng in der Vegetation. Die müssen nicht brüllen, weil sind es sowieso sehr geschlossenes Habitat,
die haben sehr große Ohren,
und haben ein Flüster so nah, die rufen ganz leise und auch ein breites Spektrum an Ultraschall und können dann richtig wie so ein kleiner Miniscanner äh Insekten umrisse von Blättern und so wahrnehmen. Das heißt, sie flüstern,
sind aber haben eine extrem genaue und hohe Auflösung ähm ihrer ihrer Umwelt und können dann eben sogar schlafende Inse,
anhand ihres Umrisses erkennen und absageln. Das sind die sogenannten Gliner, die Absammlerfledermäuse, die eben ihre Nahrung von von der Oberfläche von Blättern oder von.
Äh Baumstämmen und so weiter einsammeln. Da sind die beiden extrem. Und dazwischen äh.
Gibt's dann ganz unterschiedliche Ausprägungen. Dann gibt's auch noch Fledermäuse, die über Wasseroberflächen jagen. Das kann jeder auch abends mal selber sich hinstellen, an so ein Gewässer.
Bach oder ein See. Mit der Taschenlampe immer flach. Drüber leuchten, dann wird man Wasserfledermäuse sehen. Ganz flach über der Wasseroberfläche jagen.
Und äh dort die Mücken einsammeln, mit den großen Füßen. Die haben dann also sehr große Füße. Wir machen so eine Art Klappmesserbewegung, die man so gar nicht sehen kann, brauchst du einen ähm,
ein Highspeed-Film, um das zu sehen. Die fangen also mit den Füßen, die Mücke, manchmal auch sogar einen kleinen Fisch, wenn sie hinkriegen.
Und machen dann einmal so eine Art Klappmesser, Füße nach vorne, zum Maul führen, das äh schnappen sich da die die Beute und weiter geht's.
Also, alle möglichen Lebensräume können die Fledermäuse mit einem Spezial-Ultraschall ähm ja äh bejagen.
Äh
Jetzt ist ja Ultraschall ähm man hätte ja eigentlich auch jede andere Frequenz nehmen können, aber die Anpassung ist ja vermutlich die, dass jetzt Ultraschall hören, nicht unbedingt eine Eigenschaft vieler anderer Tiere.
Ist. Also man macht sich damit ja äh oder gibt es auch Tiere, die auch Ultraschall hören können. Wenn wir ja dann entsprechend gewarnt werden vor den äh Flederm.
Ja genau, also da gibt's äh zum einen gibt es auch andere Säugetiere, die Ultraschall nutzen, Mäuse zum Beispiel, die kommunizieren in Ultraschall auch, Mäuseratten, andere Nagetiere, auch Spitzmäuse.
Also weiß der Zologe, das sind ja auch Insektenfresser, die hören auch Ultraschall und äh können das. Und dann gibt es.
Die hören's nur oder die können's auch selber.
Könnt's senden und hören. Also die die sind ja jetzt nicht die Beute der Fledermäuse, sondern das sind auch welche, die es nutzen. Das sind Ultraschallnutzer.
Die Kommunikation genau im Dunkeln im Bau oder in der Nacht. Das ist natürlich dann eine schöne Kommunikationsform so. Und ähm ist jetzt auch im Prinzip ja,
aus der Evolution betrachtet, also ist etwas, was was äh Kleinsäuger zum Teil eben können. Und das haben die Fledermäuse dann zur Perfektion getrieben. Ähm, um das dann zu nutzen in Kombination mit dem Flug. Da müssen wir auch gleich nochmal drauf kommen.
Aber das ist eine evolutionäre separate Entwicklung, also die Nagetiere an der Stelle und die Fledermäuse, die hängen nicht irgendwo zusammen, wo.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, die haben sich ähm früh getrennt und äh.
Dann aber also auf denselben Trick gekommen, so.
Ja, das war schon bei den Ursäugern, dass die das irgendwie konnten und das ist dann unterschiedlich, hat sich das weiterentwickelt und man kann schon sagen, bei den Fledermäusen, auch bei den Wahlen, die machen ja auch Ultraschall, Delfine und und Zahnwalle,
andere Frequenzen, aber mit dem gleichen Erfolg quasi. Ähm, ist es also nichts ungewöhnliches, das ähm Säugetiere da irgendwie Ultraschall auch hören und produzieren können. Fledermäuse haben's eben sehr speziell und sehr gut,
ähm ausentwickelt. Aber eine eine Sache noch, du hast ja gefragt, können dann andere Tiere das auch hören, zum Beispiel die Beute von Fledermäuse und da muss ich jetzt noch ein Gedanken loswerden, das gibt es, ganz klar, nämlich bei bei Nachtfaltern, das gibt einige Nachtfalter,
die ähm dem Beutelspektraum vom Fledermäusen sind, die aber ähm durch eine spezielles Hörorgan, was sie entwickelt haben, diesen Ultraschall der Fledermäuse wahrnehmen können,
und sich dann durch äh einstellen, jeglicher Bewegung, aus der Gefahrenzone bringen. Also, das hat man dann auch rausgefunden. Man kann jeder auch dieses Experiment nachmachen, jetzt im Sommer sitzt man ja vielleicht mal auf der Terrasse, mit einem,
leckeren Glas Wein und wenn man dann da so sitzt und ähm ein paar Nachtfalter fliegen, könnte man ja mal den Finger so anlecken und auf dem,
Weinglas ist heute natürlich jetzt nicht an das äh Senfglas sein, sondern schöner fürs Weinglas,
dass der nicht ganz voll ist, anlecken und dann mal so auf dem Rand drehen. Mit dem Finger, mit dem Zeigefinger und dann wird dieses Weinglas anfangen zu singen, hat vielleicht jeder schon mal gemacht.
Und wenn, in dieser Gesang hat eben auch Weinglas gesangt, hat dann äh Ultraschallanteile. Und wenn man dann da so sitzt, dann kann das sein, dass einem dann so einen Nachtfalter auf den Tisch fäll.
Das ist dann kein Zufall, sondern der hat dann einfach verwechselt, gesagt, sicher ist sicher, lasse ich mich lieber fallen, der hat dich dann nicht mit der Fledermaus verwe.
Aber wenn ihr jetzt in seiner Höhle irgendwie eine Million oder hier vielleicht nur dreißigtausend Fledermäuse rumhängen.
Diese Arten sind in der Lage, so ein Lärm zu erzeugen und das ist aber dann trotzdem in der dunklen Höhle ja auch ihr Navigationsinstrument, das ist ja nicht nur zum Beutefangen, sondern überhaupt alles zu finden, hat's da schon mit diesen dünnen Fäden, also das.
Auch um Dünste, Fäden noch zu erkennen. Ist das nicht ein Höllenlärm, also leiden dann müssten die da nicht, dass er dann wie einer großen Straße wo.
Klar, da habe ich mir auch schon so meine Gedanken gemacht und werde das ja auch öfter gefragt und so, ich versuche das dann immer so zu erklären. Also, das ist ja eine Gehirnleistung.
Also man muss ja nicht alles, also man man hört ja eine Menge, aber man kann ja auch Dinge ausblenden. Und andersrum kann man sich ja auch sehr speziell auf etwas konzentrieren, was man hören möchte,
was will ich sagen? Also, stell dir vor, du sitzt ähm, hast jetzt eine Karte ergattert für die Elbphilharmonie, sitzt da jetzt drin? Hörst du ein großes Symphonieorchester? Du bist jetzt totaler Musikfreak,
und hast selber irgendwie Cello gespielt mal. Dann interessiert dich vielleicht in dem Stück, was du da hörst. Genau das, was jetzt die Chalisten spielen, weil das sind ja nun die richtig äh End ausgebildeten Musiker und du willst jetzt wissen, weil an der Stelle wird's jetzt richtig schwierig,
dann kannst du dich ja selber so darauf konzentrieren, jetzt genau die Challisten rauszuhör.
Und hörst das dann auch. Und dann ist das völlig egal, was der Rest vom Orchester spielt. Du kannst es,
kannst es hören. Und du kannst, könntest an der gleichen Stelle dich aber auch auf was anderes konzentrieren. So und so musst du das vorstellen, dass die Fledermäuse auch ihr eigenes äh Echo und die Information, die sie da rauskriegen, bekommen. Also sie können auch,
durch Lautstärke verwirrt werden und wenn das zu laute Umgebung ist, da gibt's auch Untersuchungen, Fledermäuse jagen an Straßen und Straßenlärm,
kann sich stören, in der Wahrnehmung und so, also das ist auch so. Wenn du jetzt auf das Cello konzentrierst und dann gibt's aber irgendwo Störgeräusche. Ja, dann kannst du dich da auch nicht mehr so gut drauf konzentri.
Ja aber heißt das, dass jede Fledermaus so eine individuelle Frequenz äh auch nutzt und die sich dann gewisserhin sich unterscheiden, weil wir's jetzt nicht so richtig, wie ich dann das Echo von,
von der einen Fledermaus, von meinem eigenen Echo unterscheiden kann. Ist das dann auch so eine Phasenauswertung,
die äh Tiere dann vornehmen, um zu sagen, das war jetzt auch wirklich genau das Signal, was ich losgeschickt habe.
Dass es gibt verschiedene Methoden. Genau das, also es kann eben eine Phasenphasenverschiebung sein, dann kann es ja auch,
dass du, du hast ja Erfahrung als erfahrene Schledermaus, mit deinen Echos, ähm ja, weißt du, äh, ja, wann müsste das jetzt zurückkommen und so weiter, aber wenn du kannst es auch sehen, direkt,
ähm oder bei,
Untersuchungen mit dem Fledermaus Detektor fliegen jetzt zwei Fledermäuse vorbei, der gleichen Art. Dann haben die leichte Unterschiede in ihrer Hauptfrequenz. Das sieht man dann schon. Und wenn man das selber als Mensch schon sieht, in seinem, äh, in seiner Auswertung von diesen,
äh Sound, da hat man so einen Sonagram, da wird dann eben eine bildliche Darstellung dieser dieser Töne äh gegeben vom Computer,
und du siehst zwei artgleiche Fledermäuse, zwei Individuen. Und die eine hat, ruft etwas höher und die anruft etwas tiefer, dann ist die Sache schon geritz.
Wenn wir das schon sehen, dann gibt es mit Sicherheit bei den Tieren noch viel weitere äh feinere äh Unterscheidungsmöglichkeiten, die wir gar nicht so auf dem ersten Blick wahrnehmen, dass die also wirklich dann auf ihr eigenes Echo vertrauen.
Wenn dann eine, das gibt's auch. Das sieht man auch öfter in solchen äh äh,
Auswertung dann. Äh der Frequenz von der anderen zu nahe kommt, dann gibt's auch einen Mekkerhof. Also dann gibt's äh Soziallaute, dann meckert die, hey,
macht die Frequenz frei. So, das gibt's auch. Kann man auch se.
Also Tiere passen sich da schon an und jeder will natürlich optimal ähm mit seinen, mit den Informationen versor.
Zumindest erscheint es mir, dass das schon so die Tiere sind, die so mit Frequenzen eigentlich am geschicktesten umzugehen scheinen. Also.
Ja, es ist eine Schallwelt, in der die leben. Also sie können auch auch auch sehen, die können durchaus,
am Augen, sind nicht blind, das wird auch gesagt, wir sind ja blind. Also, die haben äh Teil auch Farbsehen, die,
Fledermäuse oder können Infrarot äh sehen und so weiter. Aber sie sind eben von der Seeleistung her eben nicht ganz so nicht ganz so toll. Also sie machen alles mit Schal,
brauchen eigentlich die Augen nicht. Blindheit bei einer Fledermaus muss nicht unbedingt das Todesurteil für sie bedeut.
Wer im Prinzip wie bei uns die Blinden ja auch dann äh auf Schall ausweichen und auch mit Echo arbeiten, also.
Ja, gibt's da diesen einen, ich habe seinen Namen vergessen, diesen berühmten Amerikaner, der auch mit Zungen schnalzen. Ähm, sehr erfolgreich war. Der ist da sogar Fahrrad gefahren wird. Es war vor einigen Jahren ganz berühmt. Ich hab's leider zu einer seinen Namen jetzt.
Der der ist wirklich ähm hat dieses Zungenschnalzen für sich äh entdeckt, wie eine.
Wie so ein Flughund und Höhlenflughund, ägyptischen Flughund und ist damit sogar Mountainbike gefahren, weil er dann mit dem Zungenschnalz und den Echos.
Seine Umgebung abscannen konnte. Das geht. Man muss sich dann halt, das kannst du nicht von heute auf morgen lernen, aber ähm das Gehirn ist plastisch und kann solche Dinge.
Ich meine, das merkt man ja auch, auch an sich selber. Also man man ich habe, sagen wir mal, auch als,
als Podcaster schon so eine so eine gewisse äh Schallaffinität. Ich merke irgendwie äh auch wenn ich aus der Ferne mit jemandem spreche, kann ich ja sagen so,
ja okay, aber mache nochmal äh das Fenster zu.
Gar nicht so sehr, weil da jetzt so ein Lärm reinkommt, sondern mehr so ein bestimmte Art von Rauschen, wo ich weiß, aha, okay, das ist so, so, das kommt so aus der Ferne oder wenn der Raum halt besonders klein ist und,
das Echo daneben äh einfach sehr viel
schneller und eben auch härter wird und eben diese ganze Klangwelt mit Anreichert und klar und auch wenn man jetzt im dunklen Keller läuft, dann.
Ist man einfach besser ausgestattet, wenn man nichts in Ohren hat so. Also es.
Ja, ganz genau, ganz genau.
Weil wenn einem der Sinn dann auch noch äh genommen wird und auf einmal alles komplett äh tot ist, dann wird man auch schnell Orientierungslo.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Du kannst das zu Hause ausprobieren. Du kannst ja einfach mal zum Schnalzen machen. Du machst das mal im Badezimmer, mal im Wohnzimmer und beim Treppenhaus und also die Unterschiede schon sehr, sehr deutlich hören und du kannst sofort unterscheiden. Wenn du das den.
Oder wenn man halt in so einem toten Raum äh äh reingeht, das hat man ja in so Studios, die so massiv gedämmt sind und irgendwie alles äh schlucken, dann führt das ja auch schon zu einer, also manch.
Unnatürlich.
Genau, also manche reagieren dann sogar fast äh äh panisch äh äh drauf, wie Milagemay very, weil man halt einfach überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, wo man ist, äh man fühlt sich sozusagen wie so ein Weltall.
Äh Schallmehl gibt und dann dadurch merkt man eigentlich erst das, obwohl wir uns nicht primär daran orientieren. Trotzdem.
Einem dieses Umgebungsecho immer eine gewisse Sicherheit über das wo man ist und wie man ist äh gibt, was ehrlich erst auffällt, wenn's nicht mehr da ist.
Im Unterbewusstsein. Ganz genau. Wir haben also viel feinere Sinneswahrnehmungen, als man manchmal so denkt und was aus auch durch unser,
ja, die ganze Ablenkung in der in der Welt, die einem so begegnet, vielleicht auch so ein bisschen untergebuttert wird. Aber wenn man darauf zurückgeworfen wird, man kriegt da sehr viel mit.
Du hast das Sehen angesprochen, also äh ich hatte äh du sagst gesagt, Infrarot gibt's nicht sogar auch ähm,
Modelle hätte ich fast gesagt. Arten die ähm auch äh Ultraviolettes äh Licht wahrnehmen, also es ist.
Wie wichtig ist das das Sehen, also warum könnt ihr überhaupt noch sehen, wenn sie sowieso noch nachts unterwegs sind und in dummen Höhlen sind. Also warum ist das sozusagen evolutionär überhaupt noch da.
Naja, klar, man will ja auch gucken, äh, gucken, genau. Ähm, es ist ja wichtig, welche Umgebungsbeleuchtung noch da ist, beispielsweise nimmt auch die Fledermaus Aktivität,
durch Vollmond zum Beispiel ein bisschen ab, die Tiere gehen dann in dunklere Bereiche, ähm
weil ja eben auch Beutegreifer, wie Eulen oder so, die ja auch mit dem Restlicht noch sehr gut äh gucken können und darauf halt äh spezialisiert sind. Denn so eine langsam fliegende Fledermaus ja auch äh dann beim Mondlicht durchaus noch besser fangen können
als äh in völliger Dunkelheit und das muss eine Fledermaus natürlich auch wissen, wie es gerade so die Helligkeit. Es gibt sogar sehr Lichtscheue, Fledermäuse, es ähm,
auch so ein Klischee, dass die immer so Lichtschale sind. Manche sind gar nicht so lichtscheu, die jagen auch Insekten rund.
Wie die Vampire halt, ne? Da stirbt man dann.
Laternen, ja. Genau, die werden zu Staub, das ist natürlich eine Legende,
aber ähm hier die Fledermäuse der Sägeberger Kalkberghöhle, die zur Gattung Neyotis gehören, also eine unter Gruppe der Glattnasenfledermäuse, spezielle Gruppe. Ähm die eben auch recht langsam fliegen, recht tief fliegen.
Äh an Vegetation gebunden sind, die bevorzugen dunkle Flugbereiche, also Flugtrassen,
ähm weil sie eben nicht so schnell ausweichen können, beispielsweise für euch, die haben wir so eine natürliche Angst vor Licht, ähm als als Schutz.
Ja, ich wollt's grad sagen, ne? Also das die Lichtwahrnehmung ist sozusagen das Signal mit die anderen können die jetzt nicht mehr wahrne.
Genau, ich bin jetzt safe. So, also das brauchen die das. Also da.
Sondern muss nur wissen, ist Licht da oder.
Genau, da kann das Auge, also wenn Licht eine Rolle spielt in deinem Leben, dann brauchst du auch Augen. Wenn du ein Höhenfisch bist, in der Höhle in Mexiko, ähm und da ist nie Licht. Also, seit seit Millionen von Jahren ist da schon kein Licht,
dann entwickeln sich auch deine Augen zurück, dann brauchst du die nicht. Da hast du andere Sinne, die du ausbauen kannst, wie das Seitenlinie Organ und so weiter. Und da haben sich dann bei solchen Arten, die auch noch ähm Verwandte an der Oberfläche haben, die natürlich voll gucken können, weil man als.
Süßwasserfisch seine Augen braucht,
in der Höhle völlig zurückgebildet. Und dann spart man dadurch noch Energie, dass man eben das Sehen gar nicht mehr bedienen muss, quasi. Die haben dann, äh, das Gehirn auch verändert und so, die nehmen dann andere Sachen wahr. Aber wenn in deiner Welt irgendwie noch Licht vorkommt,
kannst du auf Augen nicht verzicht.
Stimmt es ist die Fledermäuse auch in der Lage, sind Mangetismus zu spüren.
Ja, das ist ja ähm ähnlich wie beim Vogelzug. Da sowas wird dann auch untersucht. Fledermaus Wanderung und Zug gibt's ja auch. Und ähm das ist äh Forschungsgegenstand, also,
ähm was da eine Rolle spielt, aber das Erdmagnetfeld,
mit Sicherheit auch eine Rolle. Das ist soweit ich das weiß, ist jetzt nicht mein Spezialgebiet. Bei Fledermäusen nicht ganz so stark äh End untersucht wie beim Vögeln. Da gibt's ja die Untersuchungen.
Ähm vom Max-Planck-Institut für Ornithologie, zum Zugverhalten von Vögeln und so weiter. Ähm aber das äh.
Wenn ich das jetzt so richtig weiß, soll's bei Fledermäusen da auch einige Arbeiten zugegeben haben und da spielt für Langstreckenwanderung auch eine gewisse Rolle.
Aber sind ja die Fledermäuse überhaupt so viel unterwegs, wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe, sind sie immer so ganz traditionell, die würden ganz gerne immer am selben Ort bleiben oder wird da so viel gewandert.
Ja, das kommt drauf an. Also Fledermäuse haben eigentlich schon äh dadurch, dass sie fliegen können, eine hohe Mobilität und ähm,
brauchen auch verschiedene Teilllebensräume. Also eine Fledermaus, die hier den Winter in der Sägeberger Kalkberghöhle verbringt, wohnt jetzt nicht das ganze Jahr in Bad Segeberg. Die kann ja eben auch abwandern,
und beispielsweise nach Niedersachsen fliegen oder an die dänische Grenze oder so und dort in einem hohen Baum,
äh den Schwestern und Tanten zusammen in der Wochenstube ihre Jungen aufziehen. Und dann hier im Herbst wieder ankommen in Segeberg und dann hier schlafen. Also so ist so,
Lebensmodell.
Okay, aber wir sind immer hier festgebucht, den.
Ja, die die.
Einfach immer wieder.
Kommen immer wieder, die gucken sich natürlich auch noch andere Winterquartiere mal an, also in der Jugendphase von Fledermäusen gucken die sich anders an, aber.
Irgendwann, wie gesagt, sind sie traditionalisten und,
wir kennen sogar aus Winterquartierbegehung, durch Beringung von Tieren, die dann irgendwie markiert sind, die haben so eine Armklammer dann dran gekriegt,
gibt's Berichte, dass dann die Fledermaus über Jahre immer allergleichen, im gleichen Chromnagel gehangen hat oder an der gleichen Felsnase,
weil man beringt hatte und so, dann wusste man, okay, die ist da jetzt über drei, vier Jahre immer an der Stelle.
Oder manchmal gibt's auch Albino, Fledermäuse, die fallen ja natürlich besonders auf und die hängen dann auch immer an dergleich.
Also wie deutscher Campingplatz.
Das ist, ist es solche Typen gibt's beim Fehler wo man auch, das ist so. Das ist so. Aber das ist ja auch eine ganz natürliche Sache. Also, du kannst erfolgreich sein, indem du,
etwas macht, was erfolgreich war, immer wiederholt, da kannst du keinen Fehler machen.
Oder du machst eine Risikostreuung und äh probierst immer wieder andere Sachen aus. Und du musst jetzt aus dem Blickwinkel einer Population das mal gucken. Wenn du jetzt so
Population ist eben die gesamte Gruppe aller Wasserfedern äußer Segebergs oder so oder alle Wasserfledermäuse der Welt. Das ist,
Krisenpopulation, aber wie auch immer du das fassen willst, eine bestimmte Gruppe. Und wenn da jeder absolut das Gleiche macht, dann könnte das ja auch zum Problem werden,
Nämlich, wenn dann genau in dem Moment, wenn jetzt alle Wasserfledermäuse der Welt nur nach Segelberg kommen würden und dann bricht die Säge bei der Kackwerkhöhle zusammen und alle was der Flair Mäuse sind weg. Es ist äh blödes Risikomanagement.
Das heißt, die sollten eigentlich äh das ein bisschen aus der Population aus dem Populationsgedanken bisschen streuen. Und ähm.
Es sollte immer einige in den Video geben, die dann auch mal gegen den Strom schwimmen. Das ist dann ja auch in der menschlichen Gesellschaft manchmal so, das kann ja auch mal nerven, aber eigentlich ist das eine natürliche Form äh der der Risikostreuung ins für die Gesamtpopu.
So kann man's ja auch mal betrachten. So, ähm aber natürlich gibt es dann welche, wie beispielsweise hier bei uns, die Bechsteinfledermäuse, da,
die sind so vierzig Kilometer von Sägebergwerk maximal, ansonsten sind die hier alle in der Umgebung um Segeberg und kommen hier immer wieder,
dann gibt es andere Arten, die jetzt hier nicht in Sägewerk überwintern, aber auch in Europa vorkommen, das sind die Rauhautfledermäuse.
Oder auch der große Abendsegler und die nutzen die großen Insekten vorkommen im Nordosten.
Europas. Also die fliegen dann so, da sind dann sehen oder nach Skandinavien, wenn man da weiß, ne, und da gekämmt hat oder sowas, hat einen Mücken auf einen zukommt. Das Karl ist ja enorm, nicht? Und das wissen die auch, da kann man eben sehr gut als Insektenfresser den Sommer verbringen,
ähm Winter ist natürlich kalt,
kontinentales Klima, da geht's dann auch mal richtig runter. Und da wandern die beispielsweise die Rauhordfledermäuse, wandern dann ab und gehen dann ähm mal nach Südfrankreich oder hier ins Kontinent ins ins ähm maritimere Klima, atlantische Klima,
wo die Winter eben nicht so nicht so krass sind. Da kriegen wir auch immer Anrufe im Winter, dann hey, wir haben Brennholz reingeholt, da saßen die Fledermaus in Brennholzstapel, das ist ganz typisch, die überwintern dann einfach so in Brennholzstapel, die kommen klar,
weil der Frost hier nicht so nicht so doll ist. Also die wandern dann eben im klimatisch günstigere Gebiete zum Winterschlaf. Die sind dann gar nicht so auf Höhlen angewiesen oder.
Also mit anderen Worten, an der Stelle gibt's wieder eine klare äh Parallele zu den Zugvögeln oder überhaupt zu den Vögeln an sich. Äh ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt immer am selben Ort bleiben, sondern die.
Binnen eines Jahres können die hunderte von kilometern reisen.
Ja, also.
Vögel können's dann eben noch ein bisschen besser. Die äh können dann lange Strecken auch über überwinden. Das sind die fliegen hier bis nach Afrika oder nach Südafrika oder ganz krass. Die äh
die Küstenseeschwalbe, die dann einmal von dem einen Polargebiet ins nächste fliegt, also bis nach äh,
ja, so, also die kann dann richtig riesigen Strecken zurücklegen. Das ist für eine Fledermaus so jetzt nicht dran. Die können einige hundert Kilometer wandern,
bis zu zweitausend Kilometer dann, das ist schon maximal und äh Vögel natürlich, klar, der Storch, der dann.
Nach Südafrikapflicht oder so. Das ist ja nochmal anders, aber die Vögel können ja auch haben ja auch einen anderen Flügelauf.
Muss man auch sehen, das sind ja auch zum Teil dein Gleitflieger, die können dann aufwinde nutzen und haben versteiften Flügel und können sehr gut Gleitflug machen. Das ist ja was für, was eine Fledermaus so nicht kann. Das ist ja eine andere ähm,
anderer Flugmechanismus. Das ist ja mehr so ein Ruderflug bei der Fledermaus, wenn man sich das so anguckt, dann ist beschreibt das eher wie so eine wie so eine Acht, so, ja,
und beim Vogel ähm der hat ja einen steifen Flügel.
Ähm hat dann auch einen Flügelschlag und so weiter, aber kann eben auch als Gleitflieger sehr gut agieren. Stellen wir uns einen Albatraus vor, der dann,
über den Ozean geleitet, der der schlägt ja gar nicht mit den Flügeln, der nutzt ja eigentlich nur diese ähm Thermik, hätte ich fast gesagt, die Aufwinde in die zwischen diesen Wellen, Bergen und Wellentälern und,
manifriert sich dadurch und,
braucht eigentlich nichts anderes machen. Jetzt verzeihen sie mir, wenn sie onitologe sind, wenn ich das so über über einen Daumen sage, als die Flügel ausstrecken und dann kommt er klar und gleitet dann vor sich hin und das, diesen, diesen ewigen Gleitflieger, den gibt's bei den Fledermäusen so.
Sondern die müssen rudern.
Aber dafür ist halt der Flugapparat der Fledermäuse sehr viel besser geeignet für schnelles Wänden, nämlich mal an.
Also Fledermäuse sind, äh, sind, die sind sind, sind absolut wendig. Also, sie können auf der Stelle fliegen, gut, das kann kolibri auch, aber sie können auch äh in der, in der Zimmerecke umdrehen, sie können auf dem Rücken fliegen, also,
solche solche Flugmanöver kriegen die, kriegen die alle, alle mal hin und sind also wirklich,
top angepasst für Navigation, auf engsten Raum. Also äh da ist ein Hubschrauber, noch eine Name Nummer gegen, ne.
Könnt ihr denn jetzt, äh, deswegen bin ich, so, wenn er überhaupt drauf äh gekommen, diese magnetische äh Wahrnehmung, die vielleicht bei manchen Arten äh vorliegt oder auch nicht, äh sozusagen jetzt auch.
Würde man ja vermuten, dann äh hilfreich sein, diesen ursprünglichen Ort auch wiederzufinden, also man.
Das muss, das muss es, sowas muss es ja sein. Also wir haben selber ja auch solche Erfahrungen gemacht, kann ich kurz berichten. Also, wir sind hier auch eingebunden in in ähm Schutzmaßnahmen für Fledermäuse, da geht's auch oft darum, dass man Tiere mal,
bringt und mal guckt, wie sich die Population entwickelt und so hatten wir auch ein Projekt zur,
sehr seltenen Teichfledermaus hier in Schleswig-Holstein und haben Tiere beringt an einer Wochenstube und haben auch denn die jungen Fledermäuse des aktuellen Jahres beringt, als die dann soweit waren, da rumflogen.
Und dann ist so eine junge Fledermaus, die im ersten Jahr unterwegs war, die ist dann bis nach Dänemark, dreihundert fasten, ja, zweihundertfünfzig Kilometer nach Hütland geflogen und hat dort in Mönstet, an der Kalkgrube, die ich schon erwähnt hatte, vorhin,
die die Eingangstür gefunden. Das ist also Kalk Bergwerk, da können wir mit dem Lastwagen reinfahren. Das ist ein riesen Holztür. Und da ist ein ganz kleiner Schlitz oben, wo die Fledermäuse reinfliegen. Also, die haben in Münster auch eine Menge Fledermäuse und so.
Und da ist diese Fledermaus, hat diese Tür gefunden. Das hat dir ja keiner erzählt. Die wusste genau, wo sie hin muss, da ist vielleicht einfach ihren ähm.
Äh Verwandten mitgeflogen und hat aber.
Diese Information erhalten. Und genau in dem Jahr, wo wir hier beringt haben, hat ein Kollege dort eben auch Untersuchung gemacht und hat die dann gefunden, hat den Ring abgelesen.
Und dann ist die das gleiche Tier irgendwie,
dann im nächsten Jahr erstmal im Weserbergland, glaube ich, wieder aufgetaucht. Die ist dann also nochmal in die ganz andere Richtung geflogen. Und das sind natürlich Raumnutzungsmuster,
die einem sonst verborgen geblieben wären und die aber auch zeigen, dass die Tiere,
äh eine unheimlich gute äh Orientierung haben und ob das jetzt rein auf das Magnetfeld zurückzuführen ist oder auch eine äh in einer artliche Kommunikation, dass da auch irgendwie mitgeteilt wird, hey,
lass mal nach Münster fliegen, komm mal mit oder so. Ne, ich zeige dir die Tür. Ja, weiß ich nicht, bei Bienen und Insekten gibt's ja sowas auch, da werden Futterquellen dann durch diese Tänze.
Man das nennt dann ja.
Gezeigt, aber ob's jetzt den Schwänzeltanz der Fledermäuse gibt, das äh ist noch eine offene Forschungsfrage. Da können sich ja bestimmt noch einige jüngere ähm Nachwuchs, Biologen noch die Meriten verdienen. Also da,
kommt bestimmt auch noch was, äh, äh, wie die Tiere das managen. Es muss es geben, weil sie finden ja diese Eingänge dann.
Da stellt sich mir natürlich die Frage, wie intelligent sind Fledermäuse eigentlich? Weiß man das? Gibt's da Untersuchung.
Das ist jetzt ja, ne, eine schwierige Frage. Ähm Intelligenz.
Naja gut, ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal so,
Krähen und so weiter äh beobachtet und äh überhaupt bei vielen Vögeln habe ich gerade den letzten Jahren viele Studien gesehen, die so sagen, ah ja hier, wir haben jetzt mal Tests gemacht
mit, was weiß ich, was war das? Äh Papageien, die dann
was weiß ich, gesehen haben, dass ihnen Menschen aus einem Topf irgendwas nehmen und es gibt die weißen und die Schwarzen und sie wollen aber nur die schwarzen und dann sehen sie in den Topf, die sind aber mehr drin und in anderen sind weniger drin, dass sie also wirklich auch mit Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung rangehen oder halt
Krähen, die halt alle möglichen Strategien mit Werkzeugen et cetera haben, ihre Umgebung erlernen und halt einfach wirklich sehr intelligent, muss man sagen, auf ihre Umgebung reagieren.
Was weiß man über diese intelligent der Flederm.
Da weiß man auch ein bisschen was drüber. Das gibt also Arten, die sind eher stumpfer als andere. Das muss man auch sagen. Es hängt natürlich auch von deren ökologischer Einmischung und so weiter ab, also.
Wird's jetzt vielleicht mal so formulieren, dass vielleicht die Arten des hohen Luftraums, Abendsegler und so, jetzt ähm.
Ähm ja, ich will nicht sagen, weniger intelligent sind, die haben natürlich auch ihre Anpassung.
Also sie sind schon so gut angepasst, dass sie nicht vielleicht so viel Intelligenz brauchen. Ich meine, das ist ja sozusagen auch eine eine erforderndes, ne äh Intelligenz.
Ja, ja, das stimmt. Ähm aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr hohe soziale Intelligenz da bei den Tieren. Das haben wir ja auch äh gerade vorhin in dem Beispiel von den ähm.
Vampirfledermäusen genau, gehört, dass sie das eben sehr genau äh wissen und, und, und wahrnehmen. Ähm, andererseits ist es ja auch ein bisschen individuell abhängig. Das kann man auch sehen. Also, da hatten wir auch eine sehr spannende, eine spannende Arbeit hier.
Fledermauszentrum. Wir haben ja diese Tierhaltung hier oben mit den Brillenblattnasen, mit den über hundert und das ist eine tropische Fledermausart und da hat eine Masterstudentin, ähm die äh über das Naturkundemuseum,
Berlin und die Universität Potsdam hier äh ihre Masterarbeit geschrieben hat. Ähm interessante Versuche gemacht. Deswegen steht hier.
Bei mir auf dem Schreibtisch, denn das war etwas, was unsere Fledermäuse oben im Gehege niemals gesehen hat,
und die Idee von der Angelique war jetzt äh einfach mal Fledermäuse zu nehmen, aus unserer Haltung hier. Und den Situationen auszusetzen, die sie so,
vorher nicht kannten. Und das kannten sie nicht. Ähm und dann hat sie eben verschiedenste.
Gruppen genommen, also junge Menschen, junge Weibchen, alte Männchen, alte Weibchen, äh hat geguckt, wie die darauf reagieren. Und hat das auch individuell spezifisch gemacht. Und ich meine, das weiß ja auch jeder, der mal hintereinander ein Postierrate, verschiedene Hunde oder verschiedene Katzen, das ist ja jeder so.
Seine Spezifitäten hatte und man die auch einfach, ja, ist kein Tier gleich. So und das wollte sie auch mal für Fledermäuse zeigen, hat sie gemacht. Und dann gab's eben welche.
Die waren total verschüchtert, die haben da.
Einfach nur die Präsenz der Quietscherente war schon ein.
War schon ein Problem. Wie saß denn da in ihrem, also sie hat das so gemacht, hat, ähm, die dann.
Bringt und äh dann haben sie sich wieder beruhigt, dann haben sie sie dann ein paar Tage später da abgeholt und mal in dieses Flugzelt im Keller gesetzt, wo dann die Küche Ente drin war. Also erstmal nur das Flugzeug, da sind ja rumgeflogen und irgendwann kamen die Quietscherente dazu. Und dann war die völlig verschüchtert in der Ecke.
Ja, hab's aber auch ein junges Männchen, was so die Faxen Dicke hatte, äh was da überhaupt keinen Bock hatte, hat dann diese Quieteente attackiert, nach dem Motto jetzt gibt's hier aber Stress, ne. So und ähm er hat's jetzt mit verschiedenen Futter
Typen gemacht und konnte dann wirklich auch zeigen, dass es ähm auch bei der gleichen Fledermaus Art, ganz unterschiedliche Charaktere gibt, die mit solchen Situationen.
Umgehen. Also man kann jetzt einmal sagen, klar, es gibt jetzt, du kannst vergleichen, gibt es bestimmte Arten, die.
Bestimmte Situationen besser lösen als andere, das hängt dann vielleicht auch damit zusammen, wie sie im Ökosystem halt, was sie da für eine Aufgabe haben, was sie da machen, aber eben auch ähm individuell und spezifisch gibt es.
Naja, wenn wir so platt sagen wollen, intelligentere und etwas weniger intelligente Fledermäuse einer Art.
Und ähm sie sind keine Schimpansen oder oder U-Tanks.
Aber ähm ich halte den Fledermäuse durchaus äh für ihre.
Für ihre Gruppe, für super intelligent, weil sie ja auch besondere Anpassungen haben, die sie finden immer Quartiere und so weiter. Also sie, sie kommen ja super klar. Also ist das natürlich äh.
Vielleicht aus der menschlichen Sicht, nicht immer das, was gebraucht wird, aber äh so erfolgreich kann man, kann man eigentlich nicht sein, wenn man als Tier in Anführungsstrichen blöd ist.
Genau.
Das Erfolgsmodell Fledermäuse. Wir hatten's jetzt schon nur die Nagetiere haben mehr Arten und äh Artenvielfalt an sich ist vielleicht jetzt äh für sich genommen, jetzt auch nicht,
unbedingt jetzt der einzige Maßstab, aber es sagt ja dann doch schon eine ganze Menge aus, wenn äh jetzt mal ein bisschen hochrechnet, guten Fünftel aller Säugetiere sind irgendwie Fledermäu,
ne? Und das ist ja äh gut, gibt noch ein bisschen mehr äh Lager und der Rest halt sich dann halt entsprechend auf, aber du musst es ja dann sozusagen auch einen Grund für geben, warum das so ist. Was würdest du denn so festmachen, also die primären
ähm Erfolgsfaktoren und,
ich habe so ein bisschen so so den Verdacht, dass das äh dass dass die Fledermäuse einfach so ein bisschen die Supernischen gefunden haben. Also sie sind ja äh haben einfach
sich einen Bereich oder so eine Sammelsurium von Bereichen ausgesucht, in denen relativ wenig andere überhaupt rein kö.
Ganz genau. Und das ist auch so. Guck, du hast ja auch bei Vögeln eine große Vielfalt, aber Vögel gucken.
Macht's mit den Augen, die sind halt hauptsächlich tagaktiv. Es gibt Ausnahmen, es gibt Nachgreiföge und so weiter, auch nach aktive Insektenfresser, beispielsweise, aber das ist die Ausnahm.
Und die Fledermäuse gehen nun also in diese ähm in diesen freien Raum, der Nacht rein, wenn die Vögel aufhören, da gibt's ja jede Menge Insektenfresser bei den Vögeln,
aber nachtaktive Insektenfresser gibt's nicht. Die, wenn die Schwalben aufhören, kommen die Fledermäuse. Und es gibt sehr viel nachtaktive, große Inse.
Natürlichen Ökosystem, wenn das gestört ist, wir haben großes Problem mit der Lichtverschmutzung,
in äh aktuell, das also die Nacht gar nicht mehr die Nacht ist und dadurch also sehr, sehr viele fast alle Ökosysteme gestört werden und vor allen Dingen auch die Insekten dadurch Probleme haben und zurückgehen, aber.
Auch für die Fledermäuse ein Problem.
Dramatisch und problematisch. Ähm und aber gut, sie sie können dann eben ähm.
Weil auch so eine große Insektenvielfalt natürlicherweise ja da ist. Das gibt die, die anbäumen, die Blätter fressen. Es gibt welche, die in der Luft fliegen und so weiter. Es gibt welche, die ausm Gewässer schlüpfen, jetzt nur mal so als Beispiel. Überall sind Insekt,
eine gewisse Menge da und man kann sich als Fledermaus darauf spezialisieren. Man kann, es gibt Fledermäuse, die sind darauf spezialisiert, Spinnen aus dem Netz zu fan.
So eine Spinne ist ja auch ein schöner Herbst und die hat dann Fransen an der Schwanzflughaut und heißt dann Franzenfledermaus. Die frisst auch andere Sachen, aber so richtigen Zeit, gerade,
Herbst ähm Spätherbst, wenn dann die dicken Spinnen da sind,
und erholte sich die und kann eben noch länger aktiv sein als die, als die anderen Arten, die dann als als Wasserfledermaus, dass irgendwann das Wasser so kalt, da kommt kein Insekten mehr raus,
die geht dann schlafen mit der Mitte Oktober, da kann aber die Franzenfledermaus, wenn die Spinnen noch da sind, die dann Nachtfall dann noch jagen, bis November hinein.
Kann er noch gut klarkommen, die ist dann auch aktiv. Nee, ist jetzt nicht die ganze Nacht, irgendwann wird's zu kalt, aber die frisst dann.
Hier schon geschlafen wird, ist die Franzenfledermaus noch aktiv. Und solche Anpassungen gibt's eben jede Menge und die gibt's eben in allen äh.
Äh Klimazonen, bis auf die Arktis und Antarktis. Ähm das macht natürlich dann den Erfolg aus. Du bist halt hochmobil, wenn du fliegen kannst.
Und wenn du dich auf mit deinem Ultraschall auf bestimmte Nahrungs nicht in halt einspielst, dann bist du natürlich super erfolgreich und wenn du dann noch neben den Inse.
Äh Früchte, Pollen, Blut, Wirbeltiere, irgendwas noch so jagen kannst. Also, das macht vielleicht auch die, die Diversität mit.
Genau, also große Bandbreite von dem, äh, wovon man sich ernähren äh äh kann, teilweise jagt, teilweise einfach äh äh vegetarisch unterwegs, fast
und äh auf der anderen Seite, also ich würde sagen, die versucht so ein bisschen für mich so rauszufiltern, okay, was ist jetzt sozusagen die eigentliche Superpower?
Äh ich denke die ganze Ultraschall äh Geschichte in Kombination mit Flug ist schon mal sozusagen der mega Vor.
Der Durchbruch.
Damit hat man sozusagen die Nacht äh für sich und äh.
Potenziell auch schon mal so viele andere Prädatoren ausgeschaltet und sich unerreichbar äh gemacht und dann noch dazu die Geschwindigkeit, mit der das Ganze äh vonstatten geht. Das das macht schon mal eine ganze Menge aus.
Dann kommt noch hinzu. Ähm jetzt für die gemäßigten Breiten, dass man eben auch den Winter überleben kann. Also mit unterschiedlichen Strategien.
Da kommt dann die Höhlen ins Spiel.
Genau, der Winterschlaf in Mitteleuropa oder in den gemäßigten Breiten,
dass die dann einfach äh sich eine Fettreserve zur richtigen Zeit anfressen, äh den Stoffwechsel so weit runterfahren können und in frostfreien äh Unterkünften wie Höhlen, Bunkeranlagen, muss das also als mögliche Ruinenkeller.
Weil sie tief.
Unterirdisch sind oder eine dicke Isolation haben, hier gibt ja auch frostfreiheit in der Baumhöhle, beispielsweise, da sind wir wieder beim großen Abendsegler, der hängt sich dann mit vierzig oder fünfzig oder hundert, individuell zusammen hin,
quasi so eine Art Superorganismus. Die hängen alle zusammen. Jeder produziert ein klein bisschen Wärme, oberhalb des ähm Gefrierpunkts, sage ich mal, oder so, dass die so,
sie nicht nicht einfrieren. Je größer die Oberfläche ist, eine, einer Kugel, desto weniger Abstrahlung hat sie,
ähm im Verhältnis. Und ähm das wissen die Tiere, das machen die natürlicherweise und kann dann auch so eine Baumhöhle ausfüllen, die dann eine Holzisolierung ja hat, logisch. Und dann kann die auch im hohen Baum,
überwintern. Wenn er das, wenn er dann stehen gelassen wird. Das haben wir jetzt auch erst die letzten Jahrzehnte dann äh in der Forstwirtschaft verstanden, dass solche Habitatbäume wichtig sind und dass die jetzt eben.
Dargelassen werden müssen und so, da hat sich ja auch einiges auch getan, dass ja gut, aber na klar, dicke Bäume mit Höhlen werden gebraucht und das ist dann nicht einfach nur.
Brennholz, was man dann abholen muss. Also das ist, hat sich einiges geändert. Und dann ist auch gut so.
Weil die Superhelden haben doch immer alle eine Architektverse.
Ja, das ist, ist es richtig. Und das ist auch bei den Fledermäulen so. Sie sind ja nicht umsonst so streng geschützt. Also,
Fledermäuse äh sind in ganz Europa geschützt. Alle Arten, die sind nicht alle vom Aussterben bedroht, aber da sagt man sich auch, na ja, jetzt kann der Laie ja nicht eine seltene Fledermaus von der,
noch relativ häufig unterscheiden, deswegen schützen wir die erstmal alle.
Ich glaube, das versteht auch nicht unbedingt jeder, was sozusagen jetzt äh so äh extrem schützenswerte äh äh Aspekt ist. Das gab's ja hier gerade hier Tesla Fabrik in Brandenburg.
Mhm.
Dann muss da noch ein Baum stehen lassen.
Kann man, das kann man erklären, also der der Erfolg, den wir eben beschrieben haben, gerade das Fliegen.
Einen großen Nachteil. Wenn du fliegen willst, kannst du nicht viel mitnehmen. Du musst leicht sein. Vögel sind leicht gebaut, Fledermäuse sind leicht gebaut und frag mal Lufthansa, wie leicht die bauen, mit ihren Fliegern, damit sie nicht so viel,
äh Flugbenzin bezahlen müss.
Und wenn du als Säugetier, diese perfekte Entwicklung in der Evolution gemacht hast, dass du dein, dein junges.
In dir selbst, in deinem Körper wachsen lassen kannst, bis zur Geburt, dass du's immer dabei hast und immer aufs aufpassen kannst und ihm sozusagen alles geben kannst, aus dem,
Mutterleib, was es braucht, damit es sich entwickeln kann und dann als Jungtier oder Baby geboren wird,
Ja und dann kannst du's noch mit mit einer eigenen Körperflüssigkeit mit der Milch noch großziehen, ist das eigentlich das, was ähm wirklich.
Optimal funktioniert und eigentlich das das Kernding der Säugetiere ist. Jetzt hat eine Hausmaus.
Beispielsweise kann die siebzig junge pro Jahr kriegen. Die macht mehrere Würfe, die kriegt Provor vielleicht zehn, zwölf Jungtiere, kann die alle ernähren,
und ja, wenn er genug zu knabbern ist, dann macht die das ein paar Mal im Jahr. Man kann dann siebzig bis zu siebzig Junge großziehen. Das bedeutet, das Hausmäuse, wenn sie unter optimalen Bedingungen deine Wohnung besiedeln,
zum Schädlingsbefall werden und du darfst sie dann erlegen, weil wir sagen, okay, das ist jetzt hier nicht korrekt, wir müssen sie loswerden.
Dafür hat der Menschheit den Bund mit der Katze gemacht.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Bei der Fledermaus ist das so, die kriegt ein bis zwei Junge pro Jahr.
Da passiert ja nichts anderes, die legt ja keine Eier wie ein Vogel, der kann sich ja auch sein Nest volllegen, legt erstmal zehn Eier und dann wird gebrühte, dann geht das los und dann hat man gleich zehn Junge,
Nein, eine Fledermaus muss ja. Nachwuchs mittragen. Und die kann ja nicht zehn Fledermausbabys mit sich rumtragen. Die müssten dann ja so klein geboren werden, damit sie nicht zu schwer wird, sonst hebt die ja nicht mehr a.
Dass die nicht lebensfähig sind. Und wenn die dann gerade so lebensfähig sind, dann werden sie geboren, da können dann maximal Zwillinge bei rauskommen, sonst immer nur ein Junges pro Jahr und das wird dann auch ein relativ kurzer Zeit hier bei uns,
mit einer extrem Milch gefüttert. Die ist also fast noch nährstoffreicher als die von Wahlen und dieses Jahr schon ziemlich ziemlich cool. So eine Wahlmil.
Also die werden ja innerhalb von wenigen Wochen werden ja groß und flugfähig. Das ist nein. Ja,
Genau, die die Wale, die Schluckwale, die Fledermäuse. Das ist ja wirklich schnell. Also die werden beispielsweise äh Anfang Juni geboren und ähm fliegen dann hier äh Ende August schon äh an der Höhle rum und gucken sich hier Winter.
Aber die Geburt ist sozusagen hart getimed, also.
Das ist super hart getimed und da gibt's auch viele Ausfälle, da sterben viele Jungtiere und äh wenn das eine Fledermaus schafft, ein junges,
in ihre gesamten gesamten Lebensdauer, die werden ja zwischen zwischen fünf und zehn Jahre alt, im Schnitt, also ältere und so, aber so, das ist so der Schnitt. Wenn die dann einmal sich selber wiederherstellt, quasi für die Population, das geschafft, da ist schon viel geworden,
So und jetzt ist dann dieser enorme,
diese enorme Entwicklung bei Säugetieren. Wir haben eine äh Keimesentwicklung im Körper und können dann die jungen groß werden lassen und so,
bei fliegenden Säugetieren, der extreme Nachteil, die dürfen nicht so schwer werden und so weiter,
und dann hängen die noch äh damit dann die Jungen, die werden ja relativ klein geboren. Das sind ja wirklich bei einer Zwergfledermaus, die selber nur fünf Gramm wiegt und äh fünf Zentimeter lang ist oder so,
ist das Baby so groß wie eine Biene.
Kann schnell auskühlen, wenn da jetzt irgendwie das blöd läuft und wir haben so einen kalten Wettereinbruch wie jetzt, ist gerade Geburtsphase, dann sterben da erstmal fünfzig Prozent der Tiere Quartieren. Das war's, das für das Jahr.
Und das ist der Grund, warum Fledermäuse so schützenswert sind, weil wir eben keine ungestörten Ökosysteme mehr haben.
Zieh mal den Mensch ab, aus den Ökosystemen und du hast einfach einen Planeten, der nur sozusagen mit der Natur funktioniert und der Mensch greift natürlich jetzt überall ein und es gibt überall kleine Ausfälle oder auch größere Ausfälle, beispielsweise,
wollen wir uns nicht mehr darauf verlassen, eine natürliche Schädlingsbekämpfung zu machen. Wir haben herausgefunden, das geht mit Chemie, alles viel besser, haben aber gar nicht verstanden, was wir da alles platt machen,
oder bekämpfen Ackerbeikräuter, wie das heißt, äh auch mit Chemie, dass das natürlich alles, jede Pflanze, die da sonst noch auf dem Acker wächst, wieder.
Mittelpunkt Mittelpunkt ist für eine ganze Vielfalt von Insekten und so weiter, die von der Leben und so. Das haben wir alles gar nicht gecheckt, weil das einfach nur darum geht jetzt hier äh unsere Sachen klarzukriegen und das ist auch alles,
so gedacht, aber das hat natürlich enorme Folgen und dann ist eben diese, dieser Erfolg von von Fledermäusen, die eigentlich auch ein bisschen darauf angewiesen sind, dass es.
Einigermaßen ungestört läuft, äh im Ökosystem, ähm dann die Achilisterse, der der Tiere. Und deswegen müssen sie auch geschützt werden, weil wir können einfach nicht Quartiere verlieren, wo äh plötzlich dann vielleicht zweihundert,
Teichfledermäuse plötzlich mal wegkommen, weil einer den Dachboden renoviert oder so, die fehlen dann. Und die gibt's dann auch so schnell nicht wieder.
Also dieser Populationsschwund können fliegende,
Arten wie wie Fledermäuse, ganz schwer ausgleichen. Vögel, kann ja mehr Eier legen, beispielsweise oder Wale, die ja auch unter. Jagddruck standen. Da hat man festgestellt, dass die dann früher geschlechtsreif wurden,
also nach dem dritten Jahr, beispielsweise, als nach fünf Jahren oder irgendwie solche Sachen dann. Die haben dann also versucht, darauf zu reagieren. Das ist bei der Fledermaus schon entoptimiert. Da kann man nicht mehr machen.
Das ist das Problem.
Mhm. Und dann kann's auch ganz schnell mal vorbei sein mit den ganzen Fledermauspopulationen.
Ja, das haben wir ja erlebt. Und zwar in den äh sechziger, siebziger Jahren,
als sozusagen das DDT so richtig zugeschlagen hat, ändert sich vielleicht der ein oder andere noch da dran, ein ein eigentlich so ein Wunderinsektizit, was eingesetzt wurde. Man dachte, jetzt hat man Malaria erledigt und äh man kann jetzt auch,
wunderbar an der Landwirtschaft das Einsätzen, also ein ein krasses Insektizit, was eigentlich erstmal für den Menschen dachte man,
ungefährlich ist. Hat man dann versprüht, man hat die Leute entlaust, beispielsweise nach dem Krieg oder sind die Haare geschmiert und hat äh Balken mit eingestrichen, damit dann keine da reinkommen, hat das mit Flugzeugen über Wäldern,
verstreut und so weiter, hatte aber äh nicht bedacht, wusste das einfach nicht besser, dass das ein sehr persistent ist.
Mittel ist, das heißt, was sich das zersetzt sich nicht. Das funktioniert ganz lange, bleibt in Ökosystem drin. Und äh, das bleibt nicht gleich verteilt im Waldboden, sondern es wird angereichert,
wird aufgenommen, ist weiterhin giftig. Und es ist vor allen Dingen fettlöslich. Das heißt.
Lagert sich ein, bei Fledermäusen und die haben dann solche Mengen an Gift aufgenommen. Einerseits über die Nahrung, die Nahrung wurde weniger, das Gift hat die Nahrung vergiftet, aber auch.
Reduziert. Dann hatte sich noch bei den Fledermäusen, die ja auf ein,
Aufbau einer Fettreserve für den Winterschlaf ähm angewiesen sind eingelagert und wenn die dann eben aus Minderschlaf aufgewacht sind.
Äh und diese Fettreserven mobilisiert haben. Dann gab's noch erstmal so einen Giftschub. Und dann sind die halt ähm von Tour von der Wand gefallen. Und.
Dann sind halt die Flärm aus Population in Deutschland, bis zu neunzig Prozent eingebrochen, die waren dann weg. Neunzig Prozent der Fledermäuse aus Quartieren, die man vorher, das hatte man beobachtet, man hat Zähl reingehabt, die die waren weg.
Und das ist natürlich dann Weckruf gewesen, Alarmruf, deswegen sind Fledermäuse auch in ganz Europa,
speziell geschützt, es gibt das Abkommen zum Schutz der Fledermäuse in Europa, Huro Betz, Sekretariate, UN, ähm.
Einrichtung, ähm, was eben diesen Fledermausschutz auch koordiniert, alle Mitgliedsstaaten, die dieses äh Abkommen unterzeichnet haben, haben sich für den Fledermausschutz,
stark gemacht und haben auch anerkannt, dass eben diese Fledermäuse eine besondere Indikatorfunktion haben für die Qualität von Lebensräumen, deswegen sind die auch,
in der sogenannten Florafaune Habitat Richtlinie erwähnt und spielen da eine besondere Rolle. Das heißt, man hat sich auch überlegt, vor mittlerweile äh über zwanzig Jahren,
dass wenn in Europa das so weiterläuft, das ist ja ein großer Ballungsraum, dichter Raum, viele Menschen leben hier, Städte wachsen und so weiter,
dann kann es sein, dass die Charakteristischen Lebensräume, die Europa ausmachen.
Beispielsweise Buchenwälder oder Bäche und an sowas. Das das verschwinden kann. Und deswegen sollten alle,
Mitgliedsstaaten einfach mal sagen, welche Lebensräume sind dann besonders, hat man List gemacht, was ist charakteristisch? Und wer hat was? Und dann werden sollte ein Schutzgebietssystem eingerichtet werden, was sie auch haben. Und in diesen Schutzgebieten,
dann eben auch bestimmte Indikatorarten, unter anderem auch verschiedene Fledermausarten, eine Rolle, um dann irgendwie sicherzustellen, dass,
die Natur in Europa noch genügend Raum hat und auch in der.
So vorhergesehenen und gewachsenen Ausprägungen auch erhalten bleibt. Wenn man nicht wollte, dass es irgendwie endet, wie der Großraum Tokio oder so, ne?
So, soweit zur Theorie. Und da spielen Fledermäuse dann eben auch eine besondere Rolle. Und diese seltenen,
sogenannten Anhang zwei Arten, das sind äh die Arten, die dann auch äh für den Artenschutz noch eine Rolle spielen, haben wir hier auch, welches die Bergsteinfledermaus, die Teichfleder im aus und,
das äh große Mausohr hier, die dann auch in Sägeberg überwintern. Und dafür ist dieses Schutzgebiet Sägeberger Kalkberghöhle auch speziell ausgewies,
aber ein paar tausend Pflanzenfledermäuse und Wasserfledermäuse machen auch Eindruck und sind auch geschützt. Also so ist es nicht. Aber das ist dann mal der Hintergrund, dass das nicht einfach irgendwie so eine Ökospinnerei ist,
sondern das ist schon sehr, sehr wichtig ist, dass äh Fledermäuse geschützt werden, weil sie,
wirklich sehr ein Schlaglicht auf den Zustand von Ökosystemen auch liefern können. Also ist nicht das Einzige, was wir uns angucken müssen, aber es ist schon mal ein sehr guter Indikator.
Also sprich, wenn die Fledermäuse äh verschwinden, dann ist unter Umständen irgendwas ganz grundsätzliches im Eimer. Auf jeden Fall. Mh.
Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fal.
Und wir haben ja schon gehört, so. Es sind wichtig für die Bestäubung, et cetera, ist ja auch so ein bisschen immer so diese Gesang, die man so rund um Bienen äh.
Dass das, wenn das einfach mal wegfallen würde. Ich meine, wer hätte das schon gedacht, dass diese Blutsauger, diese Vampire, äh, so nützliche äh Tiere sein können, ne. Ähm was mir eben gerade noch äh auf viel.
Also, was Herr Fledermäuse richtig gut können, ist ja abhängen, ne.
Richtig, das hat, warum, warum hängen die App? Ja, klar. Das.
Ja klar abhängen. Klar, also können wir natürlich auch super, ist ja völlig logisch. Ähm nee, das hat da ganz einfachen Grund. Ähm was kostet beim Flug die meiste Energie.
Kannst du Luft haben, sie auch wieder fragen, ist der Start? Du musst ja erstmal die gesamte Masse in die Luft bringen. Wenn du abhängst, hast du schon eine super Startposition. Das heißt, du sparst dir schon mal.
Die Staatenergie. Und äh damit haben die Fledermäuse auch entoptimiert. Die brauchen keine Energie mehr, um sich festzuhalten. Die haben einen speziellen Sehnenzug Mechanismus. Das heißt, ihre Fußkralle und die, die ähm.
Krallen werden einfach durch das Gewicht der Fledermaus, die an diesen Sehnen hängt, umgebogen. Das heißt, wenn die sich einklinkt, die klingt sich ein, hängt das Gewicht.
Einfach.
Ist es arretiert, die hängt fest. Und die braucht nicht irgendwie Muskelkraft, um sich festzuhalten, also.
Wie auch die Pferde nur andersrum, also die klingen ja da so ihre Knie ein und so weiter und dann stehen sie halt einfach und brauchen keine Kraft dafür.
So ist es. Genau. Und das äh kann die Fledermaus eben auch. Und die muss dann eben die Flügel aufmachen und ein bisschen Luft unter die Flügel bringen, dass sie dann so äh sich ausklinken kann. Und das ist einfach eine super Anpassung. Also das ist so optimal, dass wir eine Fledermaus im Hängen stört, bleibt die hängen.
Stimmt, weil braucht ja Muskel, um irgendwie Lust.
Das ist dann, äh, kriegen wir auch manchmal so Anrufe, ja, wir haben hier eine Fledermaus, die hängt schon fünf Tage lang an der Garagenwand. Hm, da wissen ja schon, okay, könnte sein, dass sie nicht mehr unter uns weilt.
Die dann überhaupt äh.
Ja, kann man ja abnehmen. Ist ja dann leicht abzuhängen, aber solche Dinge äh.
Sozusagen die Klaue.
Aber das ist eben auch so eine Anpassung. Und das ist das der Grund des Abhängs, wer schon hängt, muss nicht starten.
Und in Höhlen reicht das sozusagen, also da sind jetzt keine Fäden gespannt, sondern es ist einfach nur kleinst.
Ja, da sind kleine Vorsprünge und so. Und natürlich ist es auch so, wer unter der Decke hängt, ist auch schlechter zu erreichen, für den Beutegreifer oder so. Ist ja auch k.
Mhm, mhm.
Also das hat, also es gibt nie immer nur einen Grund, aber ähm ich denke, ich halte das die Startenergie für einen wichtigen Grund.
Mhm. Ja, und hier ist auch eine ähm, wie soll ich sagen, auch ein Film, eine beliebte äh Versteckoption so.
Genau, äh wo, wo, wo wo ist der Held in der, in der Lüftungsanlage, erstmal gucken? Genau, wissen Bescheid.
Einfach mal abhängen. Jetzt müssen wir auch nochmal so einen anderen äh Elefanten im Raum nochmal äh besprechen,
denn wir haben ja gerade äh Corona-Krise, tausendmal schon äh am Rande erwähnt, aber hier scheinen ja die Fledermäuse auch eine besondere Rolle zu spielen.
Ähm konkret ist halt davon die Rede, dass nicht nur dieser Virus, der uns jetzt gerade alle so äh inhaltlich so beschäftigt, sondern viele andere Viren auch, ihren Ursprung bei den Fledermäusen haben.
Ähm und von dort in irgendeiner Form den Weg zum Menschen äh gefunden hat,
Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich auch gar keine Neuigkeit. Also es ist äh nicht das Erste, äh Virus, was im Verdacht steht, äh von der Fledermaus zu
kommen, ich es richtig sehe, betrifft das eigentlich nahezu alle mehr, saß äh Viren der letzten Jahrzehnte, die so über uns gekommen sind.
Toll, wo beispielsweise auch.
Tollwut-Virus, ist auch ein Virus, ja? Mhm. Ähm was geht da ab? Also äh Fledermäuse stehen so in dem Ruf ein absolutes Viren,
äh der Virenvorrat der Welt zu sein. Warum ist das so.
Ja, ist natürlich aus der Sicht äh des Menschen so. Ähm und auch da,
kann man nur sagen, Fledermäuse sind ja schon lange auf diesem Planeten, in dieser Form und haben auch schon vor Millionen von Jahren.
Millionenstädte gegründet. Und äh wir wissen ja, dass Erreger oder überhaupt äh ja, nicht nur Viren sein, Bakterien oder auch Pflanzenkrankheiten oder irgendwas äh was es so gibt. In großen Populationen sich ja sehr schnell sehr,
weitestgehend ausbreiten können. Und äh,
wenn wir jetzt Fledermäuse betrachten, die in, ja, zu mehreren Millionen hier die Dreißigtausender Winterschlafgesellschaft in Sägeberg ist da ja eine Kleinstadt. Dann ist es natürlich klar, dass eben auch äh Krankheitserreger, seines Bakterienviren, irgendwas,
dort ja leichtes Spiel hätten. Das heißt, die äh natürliche Evolution der Fledermäuse äh musste immer auf den Angriff aus dem.
Aus der Mikrobiologie, wenn ich's mal so formulieren darf, irgendwie reagieren, hat sich dann natürlich angepasst. Und die Fledermäuse haben auch Millionen Jahre Vorsprung, äh was das Einhegen und die Entwicklung ihres Immunsystems angeht und das Einhegen dieser
dieser Erreger. Das heißt, für die ist das eigentlich eine natürlich gewachsene, virale Vielfalt, wenn wir jetzt bei den Wählern bleiben, die die Fledermäuse haben, dann ist es so, dass ähm,
Viren, überhaupt Erreger, sehr speziellspezifisch sind. Das heißt, es gibt eben,
ein Wasserfledermaus Virus, genau wie jetzt das neue saß zwei Virus ja ein Menschenvirus geworden ist, was wir aus dem Tierrecht gekommen ist, da können wir ja gleich nochmal drüber sprechen, aber erstmal also eine Menschenkrankheit geworden ist und so gib.
Die Menschen krank macht, bei Fledermäusen gibt es eine Menge Viren, die heute die Tiere gar nicht mehr krank machen. Und diese Millionenstädte, die die Fledermäuse schon vor Millionen von Jahren gegründet haben, ist ja für den Menschen eine neue Sach.
Wir sind von unserer Evolution her ja eher so der Hordentyp, der äh irgendwie in Kleingruppe,
die Savanne gelaufen ist oder in Kleingruppe äh in der Höhle gelebt hat, bis man dann ähm ja sesshaft wurde.
Bis wir festgestellt haben, dass er auch mal ganz cool abhängen können.
Ja, aber genau, bis man dann irgendwie so sesshaft wurde, Siedlung geschaffen hat, äh die Möglichkeit hatte, auch größere äh,
Menschenmengen auch zu ernähren, also besser geworden sind in der Landwirtschaft und so weiter. Also dieses ganze Jäger-Dasein, Jäger, Sammler, da sein, hinausgelassen haben und dann plötzlich irgendwann äh zu Zeiten des Zweistromlands gab's dann schon mal eine Siedlung, die fünfzigtausend Leute groß war.
Das ist heute nichts besonderes. Jetzt haben wir Millionenstädte. Ballungsräume riesig. Sind anfällig dafür, aber haben das eigentlich erst äh aus dem.
Vor dem Hintergrund der Evolution betrachtet, eigentlich ist, das kann man's zeitlich gar nicht so kurz ist, wenn ich meinen Wimpern.
Nicht mal einen Wimpernschlag. Äh und dazu kommt, dass das hier auch besprochen haben, Fledermäuse, auch seit Millionen von Jahren sind Flieger,
die fliegen, die können sozusagen von einem Ort zum anderen, das heißt, äh, Erreger, die in einer Höhle waren, sind da nicht geblieben, die sind, die haben sich verteilt, rund rum, damit mussten die Fledermäuse umgehen und haben natürlich eben auf diese Art und Weise eine natürliche, virale Vielfalt entwickelt.
Wir können das ja erst seit relativ wenigen Jahrzehnten, dass wir es schaffen, innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden potenziell jeden Ort der Welt zu erreichen und Dinge zu verteilen. Wir sind da einfach sehr blauäugig an diese,
für uns ja total bequem und super Möglichkeiten rangegangen, gar nicht bedacht, dass das ja,
eigentlich aus unserer Biologie heraus äh gar nicht so sinnvoll ist. Ja, wenn du das jetzt einem erklärst, dass du bist du als Mensch gar nicht so geeignet,
eine Millionen Metropole zu bewohnen und irgendwie hier lustig äh um den äh Planeten zu jetten, dann hätte ja auch jeder gesagt, ja ja,
Du bist ja ein super Nerdbiologe. Ähm interessanter Gedanke, aber äh wir machen's trotzdem, weil es äh super ist.
Und das ist jetzt eben ein bisschen was, was uns einholt, weil wir ja in diesem Zusammenhang auch die natürlichen Zusammenhänge in Ökosystem einfach stören.
Moment verschwindet der Brasilianische Regenwald in unendlicher Geschwindigkeit. Wir haben's geschafft, so viel CO2 freizusetzen. Ähm das das die Pole Cup abschmelzen und der Permafrostig äh,
verabschiedet in Sibirien und wir den Planeten erhitzen und quasi die nächste Zechsteinzeit,
äh die wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben, über das Klima so heiß war, dass hier äh das Flach mehr, was es damals gab, bei Bad Segeberg irgendwie direkt verdunstet ist. Sowas erzeugen wir jetzt gerade
in Rasen der Geschwindigkeit durch das Abbrennen der äh fossilen Rohstoffe.
Ja, haben gar nicht verstanden, wie unser fragiler Planet funktioniert. Ähm und wundern uns, dass jetzt dann plötzlich da die Welt aus den Fugen gerät an der Stelle Erreger aus dem Tierreich, ein leichtes Spiel haben.
Das kommt natürlich daher, dass ähm Ökosysteme.
Viele viele Mitspieler haben und ähm selbst wenn es äh ein Erreger gibt, der potenziell auf den Menschen übergehen kann und sich verändern kann, ist die Chance relativ klein,
dass das passiert, wenn eine große natürliche Vielfalt an Organismen und so weiter da ist und so weiter und dann verbreitet das nicht so. Wir haben jetzt ja die Situation, dass der Mensch auch,
aus den Ökosystemen, beispielsweise Busch mitholt, also Fleisch, äh, verkauft, ein großer Menge, dass man sich äh exotische Tiere nach Hause holt,
ins Aquarium oder ins Terrarium setzt und so weiter, also mit Dingen in Berührung kommt, die unter natürlicheren Bedingungen gar nicht vorgesehen sind. Und.
Äh wenn so ein sogenannter zu notischer Übergang dann stattfindet,
der sich auch weiter ausbreiten kann. Der alte Spruch, was kümmert uns, dass wir in China einsack Reis umfällt,
hat ja heute keine Bedeutung mehr, weil das kümmert uns schon, weil äh dieser umgefallene Sag Reis im übertragenen Sinne irgendein zu unotischer Übergang, dann mit der nächsten Maschine, dann in Frankfurt landet oder in Toronto,
Also das ist eben nicht mehr so. Und nun ist es halt so, dass dann, wenn solche Ökosysteme gestört sind, das lässt ja Tiere nicht kal.
Die können ja genauso Stress empfinden, wie wir auch. So, die brüllen sich da nicht gegenseitig an, sondern,
Stress bedeutet eben, dass äh sie anfälliger sind, dass ihr Immunsystem vielleicht nicht komplett gut arbeiten kann. Stress bedeutet, dass sie nicht genug Nahrung finden, dass sie, wie gesagt, dadurch immungeschwächt sind,
krank werden oder auch äh versuchen irgendwo bei Menschen noch in die Nähe zu kommen, weil die natürlichen Lebensräume fehlen, wenn beispielsweise Bäume abgehackt werden und,
die einzigen Bäume, die es noch gibt, im Stadtpark sind, ja, wo gehen dann die Flughunde hin, um sich aufzuhängen. Gehen sie.
Jetzt äh in Berlin jeden Abend äh die Füchse äh begrüßen kann.
Ja, die die Füchse sind natürlich auch sind natürlich schlau, das Klischee des schlauen Fuchses, der weiß natürlich,
wo er hin muss und auch Nahrung finden kann, genau wie die Waschbären, also der Mensch äh ist ja auch eine super Nahrungsquelle. Wenn da,
der Döner irgendwo unter die Parkbank fällt. Ja, ist doch lecker. Kann sein, kann man sich als Fuchs noch abholen. So, also das wissen die natürlich. Und so kommt man also mit großen,
Menschenansammlung in Berührung, mit,
unterschiedlichen Arten und wenn dann beispielsweise, wie das jetzt in China ja zweimal passiert, ist schon äh so ein Coronavios und Fledermäuse haben jetzt äh wie andere Arten auch. Es gibt beispielsweise Chorona Viren bei Billugawalen oder bei Fischen,
und eben bei Fledermäusen oder ein paar anderen Arten, aber bei Fledermäusen eben, weil es eine hohe Diversität von Fledermäusen gib.
Aus Arten und diese enorme Anpassung und diese Mobilität, große Ansammlung, Millionenstädte der Fledermäuse.
Alle eng beieinander.
Eng beieinander und dadurch, dass sie fliegen, teilweise auch eine erhöhte Körpertemperatur.
Der Mensch, mit seinen sechsunddreißig, siebenunddreißig Grad da, äh siebenunddreißig Grad. Äh Fledermaus hat eine höhere Körpertemperatur, wenn sie.
Da sind wir per se auch erstmal besser an höhere Temperaturen angepasst und können vielleicht mit der Reaktion des menschlichen Immunsystems, wir kriegen Fieber.
Einfach irgendwie auch besser klar kommen. So, jetzt ist es aber so, dass es enge Verwandte, dieses aktuellen saß zwei Virus bei Fledermäusen gib,
der Verwandtschaftsgrad des Saars zwei Virus mit einem ähnlichen Virus aus einer chinesischen Hufeisennase liegt bei etwas über sechsundneunzig Prozent, in wenn man die genetische Struktur vergleicht.
Das ist natürlich erstmal viel, aber es würde auch bedeuten, das habe ich in einem Paper gefunden, die haben das so ein bisschen dargestellt, dass so ein Virus, aus einer Fledermaus, so fünfzig, sechzig Jahre vor sich hin,
evoluieren muss, um dann da anzukommen, wo jetzt, sag's zwei Virus ist. Also, das ist nicht so, dass das direkt aus der Fledermaus auf den Menschen übergegangen ist. Biologen gehen eher davon aus, dass es ein Zwischenwirt gegeben hat, das weiß man von der Sars eins,
ja, Panemie kann man ja auch sagen, da sind es die Zielbettkatzen gewesen. Das heißt, auf einem Fleischmarkt waren Hufeisennasen, Fledermäuse und auch Zwiebelkatzen, verkauft worden und,
Sie wird Katzen haben dieses Virus aufgenommen. Man weiß, dass Fleischfresser auch maderartige und so sehr.
Gut diese Chorona werden aufnehmen können, dann auch umbauen. Es gibt beispielsweise auch einen Katzenkorona Virus und macht Katzenschnupfen, muss man, ne.
Urwurmzoo ist auch ein Tiger schon.
Tiger in New York, genau, das, also die können das aufnehmen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass das jetzt also äh sofort dann wieder auf den Menschen übergeht oder da irgendwie weiter geht, das sind vielleicht auch so Sackgassen dann.
Aber es geht halt weit.
Das geht. Und jetzt ist es eben dieses diese.
Aber diese diese Vermutung jetzt bei dem eins Virus, das die Katzen, die Fledermäuse gegessen haben oder es ist nur die räumliche Nähe, also das ist dann auch so eine respiratorische Übert.
Ja, das kann beides gewesen sein, das könnte man in der Feinheit nicht mehr auflösen, aber es ist natürlich auch denkbar, guck mal, wenn du da jetzt irgendwie Wildfleischhändler bist in China und hast jetzt irgendwie deine Hufeisennase und verkaufst die halt jetzt nicht,
bevor die dann schlecht werden, kannst du die dann ja noch der Zwiebelkatze verfüttern. Ähm damit du dir verkaufen kannst. Also, jetzt mal so rein pragmatisch.
Irgendwie Pledermäuse überhaupt, hast du mal eine gegessen? Das habe ich noch nicht. Okay.
Also, das habe ich noch nicht gemacht. Das habe ich noch nicht gemacht, aber ich will jetzt auch, also sagen wir mal so, wenn man jetzt.
Ja auch nicht seine Katzen, nicht.
Nein, das ist ja der, der berühmte Dachhase, ist ja nur in Notzeiten äh verspeist worden,
dass äh deswegen mussten ja immer die Pfoten dranbleiben, aber ähm diese Zeiten haben wir ja nicht und es ist ja auch äh aus anderen Gründen anzuraten, den Fleischkonsum runterzufa.
Ich meine, haben die überhaupt so vielen Mehrwert? Also es ist, ich wundere mich, warum die überhaupt von irgendje.
Na gut, Dakuba kann man sich wundern, andererseits ist es so, äh der Mensch ist auch ein Kulturwesen und äh Essen ist eine wichtige Form unserer Kultur und da machen wir ja auch irgendwelche Dinge,
die ähm vielleicht aus äh anderen, in anderen Teilen der Welt, eher als ähm abartig empfunden werden.
Und Wachteln sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gerade so, dass womit man sich durch den Winter f.
Machen, aber stell dir einfach mal vor, ähm, Käse. Das ist also die, die, die, das vergären und verpilzen von Milch,
was dann irgendwann zu einer fettigen Masse wird, die dann auch vor sich hinstinken und das finden wir lecker. Ja, finde ich auch lecker, ich auch gerne Käse. Aber das ist ja das, was beispielsweise brauchst du im Asiaten jetzt nicht mitkommen. So, oder ich sage mal so.
Einfach Rock vor und dann ist die Diskussion beendet.
Ja, oder wenn ich jetzt eingeladen wird in in der Mongolei und jetzt erstmal vom Gastgeber so ein.
Vergornee Jagdmilch bekomme. Oder so, oder in Skandinavien, da ist ein Sommerfest und die machen sich da so einen Soströming auf, so ein, so ein, so ein,
Fisch, Fisch in Hefe. Ja, damit muss so groß werden. So, dann kannst du das vielleicht auch, aber das ist dann ja nicht was, was du machst oder du kriegst jetzt äh beispielsweise irgendwie eine leckere Kröte angeboten, irgendwo im Urwald. Also das ist ja der kulturelle Dinge.
Ob das sozusagen wirklich eine nennenswerte Ernährungsform. Es ist, du meinst eher, es wird halt auch getan, es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, äh, äh, so wie Hühner und äh äh Schweine, aber.
Menschheit ist gewachsen und es werden viel mehr Leute das und das ist ja auch vielleicht ein Statusmerkmal, wenn du eben nicht,
den Burgerrohling ausm Supermarkt essen muss, sondern zu einem irgendwie gearteten, kulturellen Fest, irgendwie mal was ganz besonderes auf.
Kindergeburtstag. Heute gibt's H.
Puffeisennasen-Rakku oder so und das ist eben so. Und äh das will ich per se jetzt nicht verurteilen, aber es ist natürlich total krass, wenn sowas passiert,
und diese Buschmiet Markets gibt's, gibt's einfach auf der Welt und Protein ist eben wichtig,
für die Leute und das passiert. So und das ist aber was, was ähm das hat's immer gegeben, aber in der krassen Form, für die Masse Mensch,
dass er eine Industrie geworden,
das ist ja nicht so, dass da jetzt der Jäger aus Kurpfalz irgendwie seinen Rebhuhn anbietet. Äh und dann ist das der König auf oder so, sondern das ist ja, das sind ja riesen Märkte, wenn du dir das anguckst. Und da die Bilder siehst. Und dass da dann.
Dieses eine Mal das blöd passiert, dass da so ein so notischer Übergang passiert, aber das ist ja nicht nur einmal passiert. Das ist jetzt schon saß zwei. Das ist nach.
Etwa fünfzehn Jahren ist es mit Ansage, das zweite Mal passiert. Und es gibt Verwandte bei Fledermäusen, ja
das heißt nicht, dass du dich bei Fledermäusen jetzt mit saß, äh, anstecken kannst, da braucht es Zwischenwirte dazu, das ist verkürzt dargestellt worden in den Medien. Wir haben über den Bundesverband Fledermaus Kunde dazu auch eine,
eine richtig Stellung gemacht. Ähm und so weiter, aber das hängt jetzt irgendwie bei den Leuten drin. Ähm es ist ja auch dieses typische Ding, es passiert irgendein.
Eine, eine,
Art von Pest, die über die Menschheit kommt, dann brauchst du schuldige. So und diesmal waren's dann wieder die Fledermäuse, die Schuld sind. Irgendwie man muss ja Schuld sein, weil das kann der Mensch anders nicht verarbeiten. Und das dafür sind die Fledermäuse auch immer gut gewesen, als Schuldige da zuste.
Okay, um uns dann vielleicht mal zusammenzufassen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dieser Virus irgendwann mal.
Auch in der Fledermaus war und da muss er jetzt zwangsläufig das erste Mal gewesen sein.
War Vorfahre davon, ja.
So irgendein Vorfahrer und dann eine weitere evolutionäre äh Mutationsentwicklung gegeben hat, die dann auch bei Menschen gelandet ist. Das kann man sagen.
Das ist schon recht wahrscheinlich, vielleicht nicht unbedingt bewiesen, aber das kann schon so sein. Ist aber unter Umständen überzwischen wird, wie man sagt, gegangen, also andere Tiere, wobei jetzt nicht klar ist.
Wie zwischen diesen Tieren dieser Austausch gelauf.
Nein, das kann ja, ja, dass dass.
Kann alles möglich sein.
Ja, dazu müssen wir Forschung machen, dazu müsste das untersucht werden, das kann auch ein Pelztier gewesen sein, auf einer Pelztierfarm. Wenn ja auch Maderhunde.
Warum schön diese Blutsauger wieder.
Möglicherweise. Ein, eine Idee ist auch, dass das eine auf einer Pelztierfarm kommt. Es werden ja auch für, für, für diese Fellkragenjacken, die im Winter gerne getragen werden, echt, echt, äh, Fell,
Kragen hergestellt. Die werden auch in China hergestellt. Das kannst du auch haben,
Also, es muss nicht ein Fleischmarkt gewesen sein, das kann eben auch eine eine Form der Massentierhaltung gewesen sein.
Gut. Ich wollte aber nochmal kurz fragen, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr diesen Biologenaspekt nochmal zu verstehen, warum eigentlich.
Also da haben wir festgehalten, kleiner Mausi gibt's lange, Viren gibt's viele in Fledermäusen, also es ist nicht so, dass die malen Virus haben, ist ja auch bei uns so, also auch wir sind voll mit Viren, die äh jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer in negative Auswirkungen haben, sondern die auch tatsächlich.
Nee, an die wir uns ja über im Rahmen unserer Evolution schon gewöhnt haben.
Dazu beigetragen haben.
Genau, andererseits wissen wir ja auch, ist der Vergangenheit. Entdeckung Amerikas und so. Wir hatten hier irgendwelche Masern, Röteln und so weiter, wo ganze Völker in Südamerika, denn daran ausgestorben sind, die indigen Völker, weil die da gar keine Abwehr gegen hatten, die sind damit
nicht äh in Büro gekommen und da hat jetzt sozusagen ein Mensch den anderen angesteckt. Das, das passiert, ja, ne.
Aber wie reagiert denn, ich habe mal, ich habe das so jetzt zum noch als Erinnerung aus der ganzen Berichterstattung, dass Fledermäuse, dass das Immunsystem einfach,
anders tickt, dass dass diese Ruhe doch relativ hohe Präsenz von von Viren, unterschiedlichen Viren in diesen Fledermäusen, diese Tiere,
nicht so überlastet, weil ein Teil jetzt gerade beim Kopf zwei Virus äh des Effektes ist ja, ich meine, man rätselt jetzt immer noch so ein bisschen Wurstig, also was wirklich angegriffen wird, heißt ja,
die siehst aber.
Zeit ist sicher, glaube ich, derzeit eher gerade ab, dass es eher so ein Multiorganversagen ist und es am Ende vielleicht tatsächlich äh das Blut selber ist, was äh im Wesentlichen unter Attacke ist, kann ich alles nicht beantworten,
worauf ich 'n Ausfall ist, unser Immunsystem schwächt sich extra nochmal in der Abwehr durch 'ne Überreaktion.
Das, was manche auch dann äh den Rest gibt. Da würde man ja auch vermuten, dass das auch bei den Fledermäusen, ein Aspekt sein, äh, könnte, aber dem scheint ja nicht.
Ja, da das machen die so nicht. Das ist, kann man so sagen. Also die die reagieren da nicht über, in irgendeiner Form wird das eingehe,
ja sogar so, dass teilweise äh die Tollwut-Viren in sich tragen können, ohne äh Symptome zu haben. Äh das nennt man auch festgestellt. Ähm da.
Da da ist bestimmt in Zukunft noch eine große Menge Forschung da, vielleicht liegt da ja dann auch der Schlüssel ein bisschen äh von Fledermäusen, Lernen, heiß Siegen lernen, in der äh Immunabwehr möglicherweise oder in der äh.
Ja, gibt's ja irgendeine Strategie. Ähm ich meine, die beste Strategie wäre jetzt, wenn wir einen Impfstoff entwickeln können, der jetzt erstmal ähm einen großen Teil der Bevölkerung schützt. So, da sind ja jetzt sehr,
ähm.
Äh hoffnungsvolle Sachen, die man so hört. Also wir sind ja sehr gespannt, dass da demnächst mal was äh dann auch kommt, dass man die Produktion gehen kann, damit dann im nächsten Jahr auch die Impfungen richtig losgehen kann. Aber nichtsdestotrotz.
Die Fleder oder haben die Fledermäuse aufgrund ihrer langen Erfahrung mit Millionenstädten, mit Mobilität ähm ja auch,
Im Rahmen ihrer Evolution, Anpassung gegen solche Virenattacken entwickelt und das ist bestimmt.
Gegenstand zukünftiger Forschung und sich das nochmal näher anzuschauen. Wie weit man daraus denn jetzt Honig saugen kann für Therapien oder für für äh ja medizinische Anwendungen. Bleibt dann nochmal abzuwarten, aber.
Wichtig ist, dass man so, wie wir jetzt weitermachen. Wir müssen einfach verstehen, dass das ist ja nicht das letzte Mal gewesen. Wenn wir so weitermachen und so eingreifen in die, in die Ökosysteme und so wirtschaften, wie wir jetzt wirtschaften, mit, mit, mit der Natur.
Dann können wir uns eigentlich darauf einstellen, dass sowas wiederkommt. Und die Artenmaske vielleicht noch die mildeste Form,
der Einschränkung ist, die wir erleben. Und das hat ja nie einer geglaubt, also man, es gibt ja die Paper von vor ein paar Jahren, wo auch gesagt wurde, man, das ist hier kein Witz mit, mit saß, das kann wiederkommen. Das haben Leute geschrieben, Wissenschaftler.
Keiner zur Kenntnis gen.
Und es gibt zwar irgendwelche Notfallpläne und so, aber das man ganz ehrlich, das konnte sich keiner von uns so vorstellen, dass das so passiert. Das ist ja noch im Februar so gewesen, wenn man hier mit Leuten gesprochen hat, ist die sagten, ja, das.
Alles nicht so, das ist in China, die laufen alle mit Maske rum, ist ja krass. So und ähm jetzt ist das hier der tägliche Begleit,
So und das ist einfach etwas, wo wir vielleicht auch mehr auf Ökologen noch hören müssen, das heißt ja nicht, dass man jetzt äh gar nichts mehr soll oder auf irgendwelchen Komfort verzichten muss, aber wir müssen anders mit Ökosystem umgehen, wir müssen das verstehen, wir müssen.
Gar nicht jetzt sagen, die Landwirte sind jetzt schuld oder irgendwas, weil die das machen, sondern wir müssen vielleicht auch den Landwirt nicht nur als, als Erzeuger, von Nahrung betrachten, sondern auch als als äh.
Landschaftspfleger, Landschaftsgärtner und das ist eben auch etwas, wofür wir in Ordnung auch bezahlen müssen. Nicht nur für, für für das Kotelett. Also, was da am Ende bei rauskommt. Und das ist einfach der Punkt. Und wenn wir da jetzt nicht wirklich mal.
Vom Wissen zum Handeln kommen, dann ja, spielen dann die Fledermäuse noch nur noch untergeordnete Rolle.
Ja. Bleiben wir doch mal bei dem Gedanken. Also dieses Umdenken in der Ökologie. Ich meine, äh Leute, die sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen, die.
Ton das eigentlich seit Anfang äh dieser Krise habe ich zumindest so wahrgenommen, dass äh mehrere Probleme ein paar haben wir ja schon angesprochen. Also die Beweglichkeit des Menschen, et cetera, aber was halt auch einen großen Fakt
eben dieses fortschrei
eben bisher noch halbwegs geschützte Lebensräume. Es ist jetzt auch, aber eben nicht nur äh der Regenwald in äh Brasilien, auch China gibt's ja auch noch sehr viele Gebiete.
Der Regenwald in Westafrika ist ja schon weg. Ich meine, der ist ja in den, in den fünfziger, sechziger Jahren schon abgeholzt worden, weil wir alle irgendwie Fenster haben wollten oder was,
Klobrillen und sowas. Und jetzt äh stellen wir fest, ja, hat gar nicht mehr die Isolationswirkung und irgendwie sieht's auch nicht mehr so hübsch aus. Und jetzt liegt der Regenwald, Westafrikas, auf den Müllhalden, äh, dieser Republik und hat nicht mal
äh zwanzig fünfundzwanzig Jahre gehalten. Jetzt haben wir ein Kunststofffenster mit Doppelverglasung. Das ist alles viel besser. So, und dafür ist jetzt, äh, ist jetzt ein ganzer Lebensraum we.
Nur mal so als Beispiel, das äh haben wir alle schon hinter uns.
Die Frage ist ja so ein bisschen, das ist jetzt ein bisschen Bion Skop hier.
Ja, wir kommen etwas von ins Ledermäusen ab, aber.
Vielleicht kommen wir ja auch am Ende wieder zu den Fliedern ähm Mäusen hin, aber ich finde das jetzt sozusagen als Anlass äh ganz okay,
und angemessen auch darüber nachzudenken weil man jetzt hier gerade an den Fledermäusen halt mal ein gutes Exempel statuieren kann,
unser Wirken auch immer eine Auswirkung hat. Und dass diese Auswirkung halt am Ende uns äh gegebenenfalls mehr Schaden anrichtet, als wir eben uns von der ursprünglichen,
Wirkung der Entscheidungen, diese durchzuführen, versprochen haben.
Die hast du jetzt schon gerade äh gesagt. Und wir hatten auch schon diesen Fall die Fledermaus so ein bisschen als Temperaturmesser für den Gesamtzustand,
des äh Ökosystems auch, was uns äh umgibt.
Wo ist denn die Fledermaus? Jetzt äh am meisten gefährdet. Also was, was ist sozusagen äh also wodurch und äh wo auf dem Planeten wird ihr denn sozusagen noch am meisten auf den äh.
Ja, also der der größte Gefahr, sehe ich, äh, im Rückgang der Insektenpopulation. Das ist krass, weil die meisten.
Überwiegende Mehrzahl der Fledermäuse, Insektenfresser, muss man einfach sagen. Und wenn da die Insektendichte zurückgeht.
Durch den Einsatz von Pestiziden, aber auch durch,
die Beleuchtung der Nachtlichtemission, spielt eine große Rolle, das bringt ja, ist letztendlich auch für eine Menschen schädlich, aber die ganze äh Entwicklung bei Insekten äh und vielen anderen Organismen,
die brauchen eine Dunkelphase, die Nacht ist zu hell. Und das geht immer weiter. Also wir wir auch, ja, genau,
und äh das ist eine, ein großer Punkt, die die Elektizide in der Landwirtschaft habe ich schon genannt, aber ähm es müssen ja auch einfach noch Lebensräume da sein und man muss das einfach vielleicht auch mal,
ähm sich klar machen, dass man, dass die Natur natürliche Lebensräume nicht einfach parallel neben uns irgendwie sind und da lebt der Mensch und da lebt die Natur so, sondern wir müssen dazu kommen, dass wir auch in unserem eigenen Lebensumfeld,
die Natur zulassen können. Und ähm ja, zumindestens ein bisschen was machen. Das ist auch wie verrückt ist das denn, dass heute.
Viele äh Arten äh noch in Hausgärten oder Schrebergärten leben und und nicht mehr in der, in der freien Landschaft,
Also das hätte man ja vor zwanzig Jahren hätte man das ja gar nicht so oder dreißig Jahren gar nicht so gedacht. Da wäre man ja immer, wenn man Tiere gesucht hätte und Pflanzen, wenn man immer rausgefahren,
heute kannst du es ja eher noch im im dörflichen Umfeld und in den, in den, in den Ger.
Da wird der alte Feuerwehrturm noch stehen gelassen, damit.
Zum Beispiel oder der Dorfteich, ja? Weil der äh irgendwie glücklicherweise gar nicht so von von Nährstoffen erreicht wird wie wie wie das Gewässer im Fel.
Also sowas und und dann, eben, wie ich schon sagte.
Fünfzig Prozent der Fläche Deutschlands als Beispiel werden landwirtschaftlich genutzt. Da ist ein großes Potential. Niemand möchte, dass es unseren Landwirten schlecht geht, aber wir müssen sie eben nicht nur für die Nahrungsmittelproduktion bezahlen und,
die müssen auch irgendwie,
von uns bezahlt werden und nicht irgendwie von von Leuten aus aus anderen Ländern, die dann bei uns günstig was kaufen wollen. Also das ist ja auch ein Problem. Also, wenn wir viel Nährstoffe haben, die irgendwo hin müssen, Gülle und so weiter, dass das nach Deutschland ja auch ein riesen Problem,
dass das einfach äh ja, irgendwo hin muss.
Wir zu viel Nährstoffe in den in den Ökosystem haben und dann die Vielfalt eben runtergeht und damit man in der Produktion auch noch das Meiste rausholt, dürfen eben auch andere Pflanzen gar nicht wachsen auf dem Acker, weil sie ja vielleicht dann die,
Nährstoffe verbrauchen, die unsere Zielfrucht, die wir da anbauen, benötigt. So, also das ist natürlich falsch.
Unkraut.
Ja, das Unkraut und wir haben ja diese diese tolle Studie äh zum Rückgang der Insekten gehabt vor einigen Jahren, wo man sich ja,
Augenrieb und sagt, ja, wir, die haben ja sogar in, in ähm äh Naturschutzgebieten, den Rückgang
gemessen und wir haben doch eigentlich deswegen haben wir doch Naturschutzgebiete, dass die Natur da bleiben kann und sich da entwickeln kann und da auch vielleicht sogar einen Überschuss produziert, um vielleicht irgendwann die Flächen, die wir dann vielleicht nicht mehr für die Nahrungsmittelproduktion brauchen, wieder besiedeln können. Und jetzt geht's da zurück.
Was ist da los? Da sieht man, dass wir richtig.
Ähm ja, richtig ähm Probleme haben an der Stelle. So, dass es eben das eine, das eben auch einfach noch einen natürlicher Lebensraum da sein muss. Wir haben bei den Fledermäusen noch spezielle Probleme
die sind auch ein bisschen Opfer, das des Klimawandels sowieso, aber auch äh unser Reaktion auf den Klimawandel. Wir wollen jetzt ja natürliche,
Energiequellen nutzen, die Windenergie. Wir müssen Energie sparen, Fledermäuse sind natürlich als Wanderer und äh langsame Flieger zum Teil auch betroffen, durch Windräder, muss man ja sagen, die können dadurch totgeschlagen werden,
kriegt nicht jede Fledermaus direkt einen einen Windradflügel auf den Kop,
aber diese Räder sind sehr groß, haben teilweise über hundert Meter lange Flügel und wenn die sich dann drehen, dann ist dahinter natürlich eine ordentliche Verwirbelung,
und so eine kleine Fledermause. Ich hatte das ja vorhin schon mal gesagt, so fünf bis zehn Gramm wiegen die hier bei uns. Ähm wenn die dann in so eine Turbulenz kommt, ja,
hat sehr, sie haben das gesehen, dass sie an diesem Skelett von dieser Vampirfleder im Aus ist ja nur ein Beispiel, wie fein äh diese Fingerknochen sind und so, ja.
Da kann man so eine Turbulenz hinterm Windrad irgendwie nicht viel entgegensetzen, da ist man dann tödlich verletzt und fällt dann runter.
Sind sie halt äh da auch ein bisschen Opfer und Fledermäuse sind ja auch anpassungsspezialisten. Die wissen ja auch immer, sind ja auch tolle Energiesparer, sie können Energie sparen, da können wir von den Fledermäusen an der Stelle was lernen, weniger Energie verbrauchen und.
Chillen, wenn's sein muss und so weiter.
Einfach mal abhängen.
Abhängen, nicht, hatten wir auch schon, aber sie haben ja auch immer sozusagen genutzt, dass wir als Menschen immer mehr Energie ins Heizen unserer Wohnung stecken. Hier,
Mitteleuropa, im Winter ist kalt, da haben wir auch nicht geheizt, sind Ofen angemacht. Und diese Abwärme von den Häusern haben die genutzt. Die haben dann einfach im Zwischenmauerwerk, Winterschlaf gemacht oder auf dem Dachboden oder so, weil wir ja auch frostfrei.
Dachböden ist nichts anderes als irgendeine,
ein Hohlraum, kleine Minihöhle oder so. Da haben die dann auch hier Jungen bekommen. Wir wollen natürlich jetzt Energie sparen, wir machen unsere Dächer dicht und so weiter, so dass dann auch diese Orte, wo Fledermäuse ihre Jungen bekommen bei uns, dann immer weniger werden.
Darauf kann man natürlich Rücksicht nehmen. Da gibt's dann auch beraten wir auch Leute äh und so weiter, dass man dann eben trotzdem Energie sparen kann und energetisch gut aufgestellt ist, aber trotzdem die Fledermäuse noch einen Platz haben, wo sie ihre Jungen aufziehen,
und deswegen spielen beispielsweise heute Kirchengebäude oder alte Radhäuser, Burgen, also ja.
Gebäude mit langer Tradition und langer Lebensdauer
und eine wichtige Rolle für Fledermäuse, weil die da, Fledermäuse sind Traditionalisten, so eine Kirche steht vielleicht paar hundert Jahre, da kommt die immer wieder hin, da könnt ihr immer wieder wohnen. Und das, sowas müssen wir im Blick haben und,
der Schlüssel für den Fledermausschutz, aber letztendlich auch der Schlüssel für uns ist, dass wir eine größere Achtsamkeit,
an den Tag legen, gegenüber der Natur und den Mitgeschöpfen. Jeden muss klar sein, es macht einen Unterschied, ob man selber in dem Moment sagt, okay,
ich haue jetzt die Fliege nicht platt oder ich schmeiße jetzt diese Fledermäuse nicht vor meinem Dach runter. Das ist, wir sind heute in der Situation angekommen, da zählt alles,
da kann man nicht sagen, naja, man kann das nächste Mal was schützen, mir ist das jetzt hier zu blöd. Ich will jetzt hier mein Dach renovieren und wir fliegen hier raus. Das geht.
Wir brauchen sie alle, weil sie auch nur ein Junges pro Jahr kriegen und wir sind ziemlich amkippunt angekommen. Man muss sich jeder,
das muss sich jeder auch sagen lassen. Ich du hast ja sehr aufgeklärte Hörer bei dir. Den erzähle ich ja nix Neues jetzt, aber ich muss es einfach auch nochmal so ausdrücken. Alles zählt gerade.
Da kann natürlich so.
Kultureller Wandel, der auch immer helfen, ne? Und diese Demonisierung, der Fledermaus oder so, dieses, ach, die sieht aber nicht so süß aus, wie eine Katze, äh ja, mit den hässlichen Nasen und so und dann äh,
kommt dann schnell auch halt so äh wie bei den Spinnen, äh so diese Spinnenangst, Fledermause, sind halt irgendwie durch ihre Flatterhaftigkeit dann halt auch immer so ein bisschen,
ne, kennt man halt nicht, was du nicht kennst, dass es dann irgendwie auch immer gleich potenziell schwierig und aufgeladen und dann auch die Vampire und so. Äh,
es hilft sicherlich sehr, wenn man da auch äh,
quasi die Fledermaus ist ein Freund mäßig, also Batman hat dann an der Stelle vielleicht schon einiges erre.
Ja, genau.
Weiß nicht, ob man das merkt.
Aber äh sicherlich jetzt ein gerade im äh Zeichen der äh der Korona äh Krise, da muss der,
der gute Ruf der Fledermaus aufrecht erhalten werden. Bei dir soll bestimmt einiges aufgelaufen, oder? In dem.
Ja, wir hatten, wir hatten hier einiges zu tun. Also, es gab hier, also wir haben jede Menge Berichterstattung gemacht, wir haben auch,
ähm wir haben auch gut zusammengearbeitet mit Medien, das lief bei einigen auch ganz gut, andere haben dann auch eher den den schnellen Bericht gemacht und äh da mal so über die
tenlage hinweggebügelt. Ähm nicht mal so sagen, da waren wir auch sehr aufmerksam und haben das auch, also nicht nur wir vom Fledermauszentrum. Wir sind ja Teil einer einer Gemeinschaf.
Über den Dachverband äh,
Fledermauskunde Deutschland aber auch andere Einrichtungen wie beispielsweise Naturkundemuseum Berlin oder so sind wir vernetzt als Kollegen, Kolleginnen,
und haben dann immer auch über Chatgruppen und so immer geguckt, was es gerade passiert und dann,
konnten wir das auch ein bisschen aufteilen, haben natürlich dann auch die, ähm, ja, ein bisschen drauf hingewiesen und auch gesagt, hier so, das geht nicht und haben auch Interviews gegeben und so weiter und versucht aufzuklären, aber,
das ist natürlich was was können wir jetzt hier für unseren Bereich machen? Ich denke in Deutschland haben wir jetzt schon sehr differenzierteres Bild erzeugen können. Ich meine, es gibt immer Leute, die,
genau auf solche Situationen warten und dann da irgendwie Stress machen und da genau.
In irgendwelche Sachen wieder verbreiten und so. Ähm darauf muss man auch reagieren, aber ähm in der medialen Darstellung konnten wir da einiges gut machen und ich weiß, dass es da draußen ganz viele Federmaus-Fans gibt und die auch aufgeklärt sind und ich mich auch.
Fand das auch gut, ähm, wie ja, aufgeklärt und.
Interessiert, noch eine große Masse der Bevölkerung war, sich da jetzt über den Virus zu informieren und.
Die die Fledermäuse sind jetzt in der ganzen Misere, in der wir jetzt so ein bisschen drin stecken.
Irgendwie Teil der Geschichte, aber das bringt uns jetzt nicht weiter, die jetzt zu dämonisieren oder zu verteufeln. Also, es ist interessant zu sehen, wo kommt das her, was können wir da noch lernen
aber zu sagen, die Fledermäuse sind schuld und das hilft uns irgendwie weiter, wenn wir die jetzt vom Dachboden schmeißen oder platt hauen oder irgendwas. Ja, dann hat man vielleicht in dem Moment ähm seine negative Energie irgendwo hingehauen, aber Leute,
wenn ihr solche Ideen habt, hängt euch im Boxsack hin und verprügelt den, dann geht's euch danach auch besser, da braucht man ja keine Fledermaus, Platauen.
Ja und äh Virus, äh den Virus äh oder dass wir es fängt man sich äh in dem Moment von der Fledermaus auf jeden Fall nicht.
Nee, kriegst du hier in Deutschland nicht von der Fledermaus nochmal ganz klar gesagt, das wird von Mensch zu Mensch übertragen, du musst halt aufpassen, dass du.
Nicht mit Leuten in Kontakt kommst, die dieses Virus haben, du kannst dich ein bisschen schützen, du, wenn du selber krank wirst, hast du Verantwortung, dass du keinen anderen ansteckst.
Dann solange durchhalten, bitte, bis wir äh einen Impfstoff haben. Wir sind in Deutschland. Wir werden da bestimmt,
sehr gut äh versorgt werden. Da bin ich froh. Ich möchte im Moment nirgendswo anders sein. Da warten wir mal ab, was da kommt und solange müssen wir durchhalten und,
vielleicht auch mit ein paar Einschränkungen leben. Und ich freue mich auch da drauf, wenn wir nächstes Jahr auch wieder die Siegeberger Höhle öffnen können. Die machen wir, haben wir nicht geschlossen, weil wir Angst haben, dass unsere Fledermäuse irgendwie was tun. Da tun sie gar nicht, die sind toll
und auch nicht irgendwelche Krankheitsverbreiter, sondern.
Können einfach, weil die Höhlengänge so eng sind und so weiter, jetzt nur ganz kleine Gruppen führen und das ist im Rahmen dieser ganzen Abstandsregelung, die wir hier haben und so einfach nicht nicht gut.
Das machen wir nicht. Wir können hier und wir haben die lebenden Fledermäuse im Fledermaus Zentrum, die kann sich jeder angucken. Hier kann man super rumlaufen, du bist ja auch hier ein bisschen rumgelaufen. Das funktioniert. Gut.
Da kann man sich also super über Fledermäuse informieren.
Ja, was hier hast du noch irgendwas, allerletztes, was du noch anbringen möchtest, hast du eigentlich eine Lieblingsfledermaus.
Ihr Lieblingsledermäuse. Ich habe ein paar Lieblingsfledermäuse, also äh ich habe viel an der an der Teichfledermaus gearbeitet hier, eine Spezialität für Norddeutschland, die äh über großen Gewässern und Sehn
äh Jagd, die ist toll, dann finde ich natürlich Fledermäuse mit großen Ohren und etwas größeren Augen toll, das braune Langohr kann jeder mal ein bisschen googeln,
aber WGP eher gucken, die ist natürlich toll und dann gibt es auch ein paar Fledermäuse so in der Welt, wo ich gerne nochmal hin möchte. Ich bin noch nie in Mittel und Südamerika gewesen, habe noch da noch nie Fledermäuse gesehen und da gibt es welche, die bauen kleine Zelte aus großen Blättern,
beißen so die äh Mittelrippen von Blättern durch und sind dann ganz weiß. Und haben orange Gesichter. Ecto Füller, Alba und das ist etwas, das muss noch gesehen haben, bevor ich sterbe.
Und da gibt's auch die Vampire.
Da gibt's auch die Vampire, klar.
Okay, Florian, ich sage, vielen Dank. Für die Ausführung hier bei CAE und ja, wie immer, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, das war's äh für heute mit CRE. Wir hören uns bestimmt bald wieder und ich sage tschüss und bis bald.